so mal gucken ob es das jetzt gecheckt hat
ja sieht gut aus
hause champ
ein bisschen viel hier, bisschen viel des guten
weeps in
übrigens wir müssen was ausprobieren ich glaube das funktioniert nicht gut
deswegen ich werde es wahrscheinlich gleich wieder ausmachen
ich habe heute mal ein anderes mikrofon dran ich weiß nicht ob ihr den
unterschied hört ich gehe mal davon aus ihr hört den unterschied in der
mikrofon
wenn ich die musik nicht so laut mache
ich denke mal ihr hört den unterschied im sound
die sache ist plus die
das problem ist nur
ich
kein gescheiten aufbau für das für mein normales aufnahm mikrofon
das heißt ich wollte jetzt einfach nur mal testen ob das ob man ob sich das
wirklich lohnt also also leute hört sich das heute viel besser an als sonst mit
dem mikrofon
also ich überlege gerade ob das das wert ist das setup hier irgendwie umzustellen
weil
das mikrofon steht jetzt vor mir auf dem schreibtisch
also sprich ich habe mein headset ganz normal auf wie sonst dass ich mich selbst
höre aber ich habe halt zum aufnehmen jetzt mein mikrofon davor
das mikrofon hier also das was ich jetzt hier vor mir stehen hat hat schon eine
bessere eine bessere quali als das als das headset
das problem ist nur dass ich da halt aktuell kein gescheites
kein gescheites setup für hab ja
das steht auf dem schreibtisch das sagt also das werde ich gleich wieder ausmachen
weil guckt das problem wenn mikrofone auf dem schreibtisch stehen ist zum
beispiel das hier
also ihr hört jetzt wirklich
wenn ich feste maus taste hau
hör dir hör dir das das das das gehau ja
dafür kann ich jetzt pock lsma content machen genau
ich kann euch jetzt
ich kann euch twitch nemaus vorflüstern
huge lsma content
als nächstes gibt es ja noch pool streams
ne das war jetzt ich
ist der discord bord kaputt bord kaputt das ist
exzellente frage ich habe keine ahnung
kannst du direkt ein vergleich zeigen ja
wir vergleichen mal die mikrofone direkt
also das ist jetzt hier mein normales mikrofon also das was ihr jetzt hört
das ist das normale mikrofon das habe ich auch immer dran wenn ich videos
aufnehmen
das dumme ist ich hab dafür kein gescheites streaming setup ne ich hab
zwar hier
ich hätte theoretischen monitor stand im mikrofon stand ich könnte das auch so
hinbauen dass das gut funktioniert
habe ich jetzt aber nicht gemacht ich hab es einfach nur vor mir stehen
weil ich mal wissen wollte wie die wie die sound quali ist ne das dumme ist halt ihr
hört jetzt wenn ich hier tippe und so das sackt ein bisschen
so jetzt machen wir mal direkt einen vergleich von den mikros mit dem
bisherigen theoretisch muss ich einfach nur rausziehen und dann die lautstärke
anpassen probieren wir mal aus
mal gucken ob ich jetzt mal gucken ob ich jetzt ja ne ne ne nicht neues
mikrofon ich habe jetzt das aufnahme mikrofon dran
das ganz normale mikrofon mit dem ich ans aufnehmen so ich ziehe jetzt mal raus
max was sagst du eigentlich zu
was mister hank ist da kenne ich nicht wer ist das
sagt mir gar nichts
so also achte ich ziehe jetzt mal das mikrofon raus
und dann pass ich die lautstärke an und dann sollte das alte wiederhören
so das ist jetzt das alte
das ist jetzt das alte nur mit dem unterschied dass der
mister hanky war dein größter hater
jetzt ist mal der kann ich so viel gehärtet haben ich hab da kaum was
von mitbekommen
lohnt sich nicht zu wechseln
das alte klingt ein bisschen schlechter ja das stimmt dass das das ist so
es hat auch nicht so ein mikro was hatten der jetzt eingestellt
89 ist fast ein bisschen laut
ja 71 hatte ich sonst immer aber mit dem unterschied ich hab sonst immer
filter drin gehabt
ich habe hier den gain hoch gemacht und da 71 jetzt mal mal exakt die gleichen
settings wie ich sonst immer hatte
71 das ist jetzt ein ticken zu leise
das ist jetzt ein ticken zu leise
mal gain an
und jetzt ist der sound jetzt ist der sound exakt so wie sonst immer hatte
ja ich muss mal gucken
da lasse ich jetzt erstmal so
da lasse ich jetzt erstmal so wie gehabt
wie viel hat das neue gekostet keine ahnung das habe ich schon fünf jahre
oder so
das nehme ich ja das das mikro was ich eben dran hatte das habe ich ja sonst
auch immer wenn ich videos aufnehme
übrigens leute gestern ich habe gestern die bitrate gar nicht hoch
gestellt
dafür sah das game echt relativ gut aus ich habe mit 4,9 mbit gestreamt
aber gut das sind half life one graphics
ich bin mir noch nicht sicher ob ich das ist ja kein neues mikrofon
das ist mein ganz normales blue yeti was ich seit fünf jahren oder so da hab
ja das headset produziert plopp geräusche das stimmt
da ist zwar ein plopp shots drauf aber
da kannst du nicht leider leider nicht all zu viel machen
ich meine ich könnte ich könnte
ich könnte das headset weiter weg machen ja
aber das hört sich halt einfach dumm an wenn ich das headset weiter weg hab
wartet mal ich muss mir das mal kurz ich muss mir das mal kurz selbst anhören
warte mal wie ging das hier nochmal advanced
quate quate
naja also so höre ich mich doch schon bisschen weiter weg ich meine so so
müsste doch eigentlich schon besser sein
ich hör das ja auch bei mir auf dem ohr dass ich so besser anhört
ich finde halt nur
dass ich ich kling so aggressiv in streams immer
über das mikro über die über das headset mikro
ich finde es hört sich viel entspannter an und viel
neutraler in in uto in den youtube videos
du kriegst immer aggressiv ernsthaft
das headset hört sich greller an ja
jaja genau genau
man kann das sicherlich auch
ein bisschen hier am
irgendwie ich mach mal kurz den kompressor einfach mal aus
einfach kompressor stellt aus oder ist viel zu leise
das hört sich jetzt das hört sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ziemlich platt an
das headset ist vermutlich dynamisch das mit mikrofon vermutlich ein content ja genau
so sieht es aus
dachte du bist aggressiv
ne das ich
nene heute ich meine es jetzt ernsthaft das hört sich so
so so gestresst immer an wenn ich wenn ich irgendwie ins mikro dabei
stimmt das überhaupt nicht
vielleicht muss ich noch ein bisschen einmal
vielleicht mache ich einfach mal rtx voice an
mal ausprobieren damit
ja gut ok leute also da würde ich sagen wir spielen das jetzt mal fertig also
plan für heute ist
ups dankeschön stbr für den sub
16 monate
jetzt habe ich gerade passend schluck auf perfekt perfekter einstieg
hyper subscription hier
max was sagst du zur aktuellen grafikkartengeneration
situation ich sag dazu
solltest täglich den preis jam checken
wo es was gibt
und feststellen dass es nichts gibt
und wenn dann das doppelte vom uvp
ok soll ich mir mal das hater video angucken also das das ist angeblich
mein größter hater
wenn er kann er nicht so
der kann er nicht so krass hätten oder
der kann er nicht so krass hätten
wenn er zuletzt vor neun jahren was gemacht hat
krasse hater
messer
ich kenne nur noch den typ
ich hatte mal so ein so ein kind das auch übelst rumgeheitet hat vor zehn
jahren
und
der hat dann bei sich auf dem channel
in den joint geraucht oder so
und es haben dann die leute reportet
und dann wurde sein channel gesperrt
kann ich mich auch daran erinnern
die gekämpfte zwölfjähriger
in zwölfjährigen
das war so geil
in zwölf ich weiß dass er hat übelst rumgeheitet
in den zwölf 13 jähriger
und dann bin ich bei ihm auf dem channel gewesen hab geguckt da hat er in den
joint geraucht
das habe ich da mal ein video erwähnt und ich habe nicht gesagt leute geht hin
und und und
reportet oder so
aber die leute haben es natürlich mit gefundenes fressen ja
so
trotz chat gucken
das danach mal danach
aber stellen
stellenanzeigen raussuchen falls derjenige am start ist
der mit diesem
in fra
structure diese piraten
diese piraten stellenanzeige gepostet hat er kann er die blitz
noch mal posten
weil
die will ich ins nächste video rein nehmen ansonsten muss ich
ach da ist doch
exzellent
genau in frahr structure engineer gesucht
das wollte ich mit reinnehmen ins nächste video
ein teil unserer crew beim letzten all hook on deck
or das ist so krönscht
hoffmann das ist so krönscht
hast auch gelesen ja aber ich hab da noch kein witt drüber gemacht schmalz
ein witt drüber
die nächsten tage
ok leute ich würde sagen auf geht's
spielen wir das mal durch ich weiß nicht wie lange es geht
all zu lang kann das ganze bei der wein nicht mehr funktionieren
äh nicht mehr ich laber mal ein blödsinn alle
all zu lange kann das ganze nicht mehr gehen denn
ähm
aber kommt noch gar nicht zurück denn
wir sind
schon bestimmt drei stunden oder so am start und das spiel geht angeblich nur
drei bis vier stunden
schreck moment ich lade jetzt mal neu dass wir
ok dann fangen wir mal an erstmal schön nachladen
und danach also ich wollte ja noch mal eins sagen bevor wir anfangen also jetzt
erstmal spielen wir
echoes durchspielen das ist punkt eins heute
dann
machen wir kurz afklo pause
und dann machen wir
stellenanzeigen
und dann machen wir stellenanzeigen vorbereitung für witt
so sieht das aus
das war man heute
menschen die ihre archive als rar verpacken
das war pings champ
das war tage ich hoffe die machen hier das ich hoffe das ist hier ihr
daily daily stand up scrum kanban tribe meeting
das kommt auch noch irgendwann leute ich sag's euch dieses ganze agile zeug was
es jetzt gibt
irgendwann kommt dann einer der macht einen meta agile und dann nimmt dann
quasi alle sachen und macht da so einen daily programm draus also du machst
da nicht nur kanban boards du machst da nicht nur daily scrum du machst da nicht
nur tribe und dings und sonst was meeting du machst das dann alles in
einem das ist dann der nächste agile shit
hast dann acht stunden programm
guck dir mal die ganzen
videos an
auf youtube
so ist der job eines software engineers
diese ganzen videos
die kommen auf die arbeit
dann fordern sie erstmal eine banane
dann machen sie sich einen kaffee
dann labern sie eine runde da spielen sie eine runde tisch kicker
dann setzen sie sich mal kurz an rechner und checken ihre mails
dann spielen sie eine runde xbox dann gehen sie in die kantine mittagessen
dann gehen sie in die kantine mittagessen
dann machen sie irgendwie das daily meeting dann setzen sich nochmal kurz an
rechner und programmieren 20 minuten
dann gehen sie ins ins fitness studio was im in dem dings so und dann gehen sie
dann um
22 uhr kommen sie heim und haben am tag 20 minuten programmiert
realität pur
ganz normaler tag
so irgendwie ist heute irgendwie liegt mir mein headset kabel im weg heute was
ist denn da los
was was soll das denn
das liegt sonst nie im weg
wenn es nur so wäre ja
ist so
leider
ist die realität und das wie die das in solchen videos darstellen halt
oftmals
bisschen
bisschen auseinander
was agile jobs punkt so was gibt es ernsthaft
privacy error
warte mal was das für eine seite
da gehe ich nicht drauf
keine chance hier keine chance
ok auf gehts leute jetzt aber
jetzt werden sie weggeschneidet
wie
die
das ist ja was wir jetzt machen
achtung diese komischen dinger brauchen wir sonst eh nicht
nein nein
du lässt mich in ruhe
das habe ich jetzt ziemlich dumm geworfen das teil
das ist
ok
ich muss neuladen ich bin zu dumm ich bin zu dumm diese diese waffen zu
verwenden
ist ja echt krass
man sollte eigentlich annehmen ein spiel was ich gespielt habe seit ich 16 bin
oder so
bin ich irgendwie bin ich irgendwie in der lage sinnvoll zu bedienen aber es ist
gerade echt nicht nicht nicht
nicht so dem eins
prokonfirm
jetzt aber
wunderbar
ex
ok jetzt wird er aufgefressen
wie
das ist wieder auf mich drauf
ok da oben waren auch so fette dinger die werden wir jetzt einfach in die luft sprengen
pass mal auf
und
richtig zerfetzt sind sie
da kommt der boomer zum vorschreien ist so
ich finde es ja gut dass die mit sich selbst kämpfen
da muss ich nichts machen
die kriegen jetzt shotgun ins gesicht
das war ziemlich pepega da ich da jetzt einfach raus gejumpen
massiv pepega
aber die dinger können nix
die dinger können gar nix
was in dem mod sehr merkwürdig ist
die haben die mp5
die haben die mp5 ziemlich genervt die trifft kaum noch was
guck mal wie die rum schießt
triffst du gar nix
ok nice
oh was ist das
wetten das ist natürlich
also manchmal muss ich ja sagen
manchmal sind die gegner echt dumm ne
ich mein
das ist ein osprey hingestellt der fliegt darum macht nix
und genau darauf ausgerichtet
habe ich so eine kanone die jetzt wahrscheinlich abschießen wird
mehr revolution als battlefield 4 leute
oh was jetzt
geht das jetzt hinter mir auf
da
keck wait
wo soll ich denn wissen dass es da jetzt explodiert
haben wir es jetzt
hier mal kurz loot kurz mal loot abchecken
hier ist nix
was die wirklich gut gemacht haben was mir sehr gut gefällt
dass das hier der anfang ist also sprich gerade wo wir hier rumlaufen ist genau das
wo wir am anfang schon mal durchgelaufen sind
ich mag so mod also ich mag nicht notorisches backtracking oder so das finde ich nervig
aber was ich mag ist wenn dies immer wenn die zu wiedererkennungs sachen hat
ich mochte es auch im originalen half life
kann es sein dass die sound effekte mega laut
stimmt es ist zu laut leute
ne passt eigentlich eigentlich eigentlich gut eingestellt
was ist die mod das ist quasi die half life story diesmal aus sicht von einem wissenschaftler in black mesa
wir haben aber gestern schon das zum größten teil durchgespielt
was die übrigens nicht erklären ist warum der wissenschaftler so der geile der geile shooter man ist und alles ownen kann
weil ich meine als wissenschaftler ist man jetzt normalerweise mit mit so einem m4 oder mit so einem m16 und
und pistolen jetzt nicht unbedingt so gut also
so was haben wir hier am start minen kleinteile zeugs mp5 immer mp5
by the way es sieht aus wie eine m16 aber es ist laut half life story ne mp5
was hier leutz wow panzer der pence man ist am start
ja die sound effekte sind schon ganz schön laut oder das schreit einem ganz schön ins order typ
man ist sicher ob sound effekt oder sound volume
ist angenehm ja klar ja klar ok sehe ich das richtig das ist die übliche geschichte
es ist die übliche geschichte da ist ein panzer und ich kriege jetzt ein raketenwerfer null immer der
gleiche kram die logik die logik wird es mir nie erschließen warum zufälligerweise immer
eine granatwerfer ein raketenwerfer umlegt wenn man anbrauch
mach ich einfach mal ein bisschen strafe
ne der ist nicht down
oh fuck man wie warum ist der nicht down da oben sind noch mehr ist noch mehr
lasst mich in ruhe panzer
der ist aber ordentlich stabil jetzt aber immer noch nicht
wtf selten das teil aus ok renn gone renn hier ist noch was
nein panzer du bist zu langsam
ok vielleicht müssen wir von hinten drauf schießen wir müssen von hinten drauf schießen
ah natürlich alles klar in den bobs genau
muss ich bestimmt aufpassen dass ich nicht erstreikt werde
guckt euch mal massive textur einfach
sack sack sack sack sack wir machen das jetzt anders wir machen stelz stelz action
wir machen keine stelz action wir nehmen einfach die letzte rakete
so haben wir den ersten gerippt schon mal und jetzt in den kopf
voll rein ich snipe jetzt einfach zack einen haben wir noch einen haben wir noch oder
wir haben sogar noch zwei
sack schreckt genau der letzte kriegt ein revolver in kopf
na gut es war kein revolver in kopf
fuck you last stand
pass mal auf shotgun
ich glaube da hat die kadi gerade ein bisschen ausgesetzt
bei der armbrust ist auch ein delay dazwischen armbrust ist halt der pfeil fliegt halt
soll mal kurz reloaden ich gehe mal davon aus dass wir jetzt hier durch müssen
nein müssen wir nicht
da ist noch ein panzer ich habe keine muni mehr
das macht immer bock
richtig rein gebadet
sixhead sixhead bait
haben wir da
schieße rote fässer es ist es ist auch immer wieder erstaunlich dass in so
ziemlich jeder forschungseinrichtung an jeder ecke hoch explosive rote fässer
stehen wo sind die eigentlich real life leute ich fahre im echten leben ich fahre
jeden tag am südbahnhof in frankfurt vorbei da sind ganz also am
ostbahnhof in frankfurt davor da sind ganz viele container und ich habe noch
nicht ein rotes fast gesehen was dann explodiert ist
muss mal welche platzieren ich glaube das ist illegal
annele genau
jetzt sofort geste weg wo muss jetzt hin da ist ein panzer moment ich muss den
panzer das ding abschießen lassen leute 102
messen wie welt messen wie bei den passt auf ja oder auch nicht oder
ok ok game was willst du vor da ist grün da muss hin man muss immer dahin wo
grün ist das haben die in dem gelben gut gemacht da wo grün ist geht es lang
außerdem war hier vorher ich glaube ich muss hier oben lang
bleibst du weg gehst du weg fisch bei weg loch spätet neue waffe neue weapon
neue weapon und jetzt wird er jetzt wieder gelasert
ich gehe mal davon aus damit kann man kaputt machen
ich habe die hälfte meiner leben verloren aber das war es wert safe alter
war das laut ja habe ich das game irgendwie ist das ist das lauter als
gestern sollte eigentlich nicht sein
bin da auf wie sie klappt also ganz ein stückchen leiser machen das ganze
was jetzt ich brauche leben ich kann es nicht weiterfalten ich brauche ich brauche
ich brauche massive life ich bin stark ich bin stark ich bin fucking stark
na geil gut job mod gut job ok wo kriege ich jetzt noch ein leben her hier ist
zu ok jetzt nicht weiter hier life life exquisite
jetzt spornhunde zack dauernd squid jetzt ist ja gut jetzt ist
ok die dinger snipen war
lasst mich in ruhe das sind die kackdinger sind die unverwundbar
die dinger haben ich auch im original half life mega abgefuckt
ich bin ich jetzt verreckt in der cutscene
ane ok alles gut alles gut wenn cutscene erst mal gestartet ist kann
am nächsten mal passieren diagonal agil nein man ist nicht diagonal agil man
skaliert diagonal da muss man schon richtig benutzen hier
confused
was jetzt der anfall von half life
was zum
ok an alle krassen half life lore story kenner was genau möchte mir das spiel sagen
was genau ist los
war das das ich meine da war es war gordon am start es war alex am start der
g man war am start der vater von alex war am start das heißt im endeffekt das muss
von der timeline jetzt eigentlich zu zu episode 2 oder so sei es jetzt eigentlich
zu zu episode 2 oder so sein was ok ich muss nicht alles verstehen easy easy easy
easy life man hier trick trick trick 17 machen
prägt plus nix alles verstanden easy obvius komplett komplett klar was was passiert
bin ich denn jetzt überhaupt ich habe auch keine waffen mehr und sonst was
der licht anmachen
was geht jetzt
ok ich habe legit absolut keinen passen schimmer was passiert ich ich sehe nur
dass das richtig poggers kinder spielzeug hat mit diesem mit diesem
kistenträger von blecknässer was passiert ich habe keine ahnung
da liegen da liegen da liegen einfach leichen im kleiderschrank
ob das alles kanon ist das ist ein watt das kann ich kanon sein aber er versucht
ja zumindest irgendwie darauf bezug zu nehmen ich habe keine ahnung ich habe
legit kein schimmer
ok dass die man hat das ding gerecht
was
alarm alarm
leute ich habe null plan was ansatzweise abgeht aber er hat sich echt mühe
gegeben beim inszenieren
fertig alles klar ok das hätten wir gestern auch durchspielen können das
hatte nur viertel stunden länger gedauert das hätten wir gestern auch
durchspielen können easy ok ok fazit fazit optisch auf jeden fall eines der
besten goldsauce half life 1 mods überhaupt also ich denke mal dass jetzt
vorbei ist
ansicht war der mod echt gut kann es nicht sagen drei drei stunden
dreieinhalb stunden drei bis vier stunden vier stunden wäre ein bisschen
lahm teilweise vier stunden ziemlich klassische half life half life stels
und was was ich muss sagen das beste war echt so die zu zweit zu die ersten
zwei drittel wo du wo du noch auf munition und so was achten musstest das
letzte drittel war halt typisches bämbel bämbel die story war nicht
wirklich nachvollziehbar ich muss aber auch sagen ich habe keinen plan von
half life story nach so vielen jahren noch ja aber ich fand die mod echt
nice kann ich jedem empfehlen zu spielen hat echt bock gemacht aber ich bin eh
half life fanboy also ich meine ich habe die story ich habe die story so weit
kapiert bis zum schluss na also es war so das lief parallel zu den events von
half life 1 sie haben es ein bisschen verpasst dass man mal irgendwie freeman
sieht oder so ok es lief parallel zu den events von half life 1 und du warst halt
dabei als wissenschaftler so was die uns jetzt am schluss damit sagen wollten
mit gordon und irgendwie in dem baby und dem g man und ich habe keine ahnung ich
habe ernsthaft absolut keine ahnung da müssen wir gleich googeln danach
half life echoes ending explained oder so weil das da bin ich zu da bin ich zu
low brain für
gone plus alex gleich baby ne oder das ist jetzt glaube ich ein bisschen zu
weit interpretiert so
die bumsen der chat gatschi bass alles klar der chat hat es wieder ausgefigert
ja
der chat weiß wieder bescheid
kommt noch was postchamp nein ok das was echt geiler mod die frage ok half life
echoes ending explained
half life echoes proposition was ist denn was heißt dann proposition
zusammenfassung oder oder was
in germann vorschlag
erstimmt das heißt wirklich vorschlag ja proposal dachte ich ist vorschlag aber
proposal aussatz adoch doch doch doch also so quasi die essenz aus dem ganzen so
die aussage die aussage davon ok zeigt mal her jetzt jetzt lassen wir uns mal
erklären was uns das ganze sagen sagen sollte
ach nee doch nicht
ok ending in half life what the hell is going on
exakt die frühe genau das denke ich mir auch
ok
ok man hat kein das hat keiner den plan
es hat im prinzip keiner den plan
ok dass das sind jetzt das sind gekattet enemy aus half life 1 war das habe ich
auch schon gecheckt
was
das ist jetzt aber echt fast recht der chat ist der meinung dass
im die leiche hier im war im wandschrank ist die mutter von alex
wat bat why warum wie soll man da drauf kommen
ich check nicht mehr das ist mir zu oder da bin ich zu lauer q für glaube ich um
das ende zu verstehen aber das macht ja nichts man muss sich alles verstehen
zu 3 hat leute zu 3 hat gut dann stellen wir mal um würde ich sagen
machen wir erstmal dna analyse genau sondern stellen wir mal um von retro nach
just chatting
stellen anzeigen mit peter agila
video vorbereitet ist video vorbereitung ein wort video vorbereitung wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich
mal neuen titel zack exquisite wenn ich sicher einfach bittest du stimmt das geht
immer so hat es den titel angepasst
zeig her
also
also danach moment danach muss weg danach muss weg ok perfekt wunderbar also
sehr nice also nice amott kann man echt empfehlen zu spielen
ende habe ich nicht gecheckt ende war mir wirklich zu massive brain
kennst du diese studiere jetzt lehramt informatik youtube video werbung nee
ich kenne aber ein der lehrer der lehramt studiert den kennt ihr auch wir haben
schon eine weile nicht beim chat gesehen
genau der
die story war nicht nachvollziehbar ja auf jeden fall ja wo ist der cute mod ja
entweder es gibt zwei varianten entweder muss der cute mod lernen hat keine zeit
oder der cute mod versucht immer noch das lehramts grill von sich zu überzeugen
und es hat geklappt deswegen hat er keine zeit man weiß nicht man weiß nicht
die werden drin gesucht es werden sowohl informatiker als auch lehrer drin
gesucht wobei ich halt keinen bock hätte ehrlich gesagt lehrer zu werden
sage ich euch wie es mir geht normale menschen schon extrem auf den sack wie
ist das dann wie ist wie ist das erst mit schülern schüler sind ja noch nerviger
ich weiß wie ich als schüler war und ich hätte wirklich keinen bock auf
schüler
ja ist echt so schüler sind nervig und lehrer lehrer würde ich im leben nicht
anwollen lehrer ist eines der schlimmsten berufe überhaupt das kannst
du glaube ich glaube du kannst lehrer gar nicht 30 jahre machen ohne
komplett verrückt zu werden
das ist nicht im nicht im scope
dass das schüler nervig sind kann ich vollkommen zustellen aktuell ja siehst
du ist so schüler sind massiv nervig also ich habe gesagt leute nachdem wir
echoes durchgespielt haben muss ich eine kurze pause machen deswegen gehe ich
jetzt mal schnell auf klo und ich überlege gerade was ich im hintergrund
laufen lasse ich mache einfach werbung für mein aktuelles video keck wait
nee ich lasse den chat auf leute ich lasse den chat auf mal pippe dance an und
ich gehe jetzt mal kurz aufs klo ich bin in zwei drei minuten wieder da
mal hier schreibe es hin auf klo so ich bin gleich wieder da
ja
so da bin ich wieder auf klo ist beendet hoch was denn hier los
warum ist dann ein anderes emote als ich weg als wir als ich weggegangen bin
war der chat das wer war das von euch chat
der chat der chat war in habe ich gesehen
was nee das kann nicht sein meinte ich war das wirklich selbst
ja wie kommt ihr denn auf solche sachen also das wird sowas würde ich doch
nicht machen sie beide euch doch nicht vom klo aus
reveal ich war es tatsächlich selbst
ich weiß kommt jetzt unerwartet hätte keiner mit gerechnet
es ist ja ok auf geht's also welche seiten guckt man mal golem jobs was zum ich
wollte schon golem jobs das ist aber verrutscht auf der reihe von von von der
tastatur golem jobs gucke ich immer gerne weil da sind immer so richtig crap
anzeigen sondern was depth stone kann man noch gucken übrigens wisst ihr was
mein linkedin peter agile mein linkedin account gibt es immer noch
ich kann mir das nur so erklären das linkedin das youtube video kennt oder
irgendwie das als werbe account geflagt hat weil ansonsten müsste das doch schon
längst weg sein ich meine dass das nicht peter agile ist und dass er kein cloud
native agil gett ob solution chief engineer officer ist sollte doch glaube
ich zu ziemlich jedem einleuchten oder gibt es immer noch ja ich habe leider
die zugangsdaten hier nicht sonst könnte ich mal nachgucken wer mich von euch
schon geerdet hatten wenn ich ja ich wurde angeschrieben ja ja ich wurde
angeschrieben ich habe hier unten hast ja normalerweise wenn da eingelogt
dass eine inbox da waren einige nachrichten ist aber schon her ist aber
schon zwei monate her wo ich mich da mal eingeloggt hat ich habe jetzt hier
leider die zugangsdaten nicht ich habe bestimmt habe ich bestimmt hat sogar
peter agil ein paar hethand anfragen gekriegt so nach dem motto huge job
opportunity frankfurt am main kann ich mir gut vorstellen
ok leute wenn ihr gute job anzeigen habt die wir uns mal angucken sollten dann
dann nur her damit also die die müssen wir uns noch mal angucken weil die will
ich im nächsten video zeigen die fand ich an sich ganz cool weil es fängt
an der rest ist aber vollkommen ok also wir gucken jetzt mal ganz deutschland
deutschland weit suchen wir deutschland weit natürlich deutschland weit was
was sonst techniker in das ist aber nicht mehr korrekt korrekter weise muss das
techniker sterntchen innen heißen oder techniker und an das i groß weil
ansonsten ansonsten ist triggert die falschen leute it suchen wir it wir haben
16.210 passende jobs für sie gefunden das aber nett von euch dass sie das
jetzt zufällig nur für mich hermes gibt es kein mwd mehr doch doch mwd ist ja
gerade der angesagte shit jetzt der fox entwickler bei denen haben wir schon mal
geguckt bei denen man die stellenanzeigen ziemlich langweilig da war überhaupt
nichts drin blablabla die übliche geschichte blablabla langweilig ok
guck mal wir gucken mal ganz kurz drüber was wollen die dann haben du verfügst
bereits über der fops erfahrung insb. mit tools wie jenkins confluence hier ja
dreierer dreierer java und nett ei was ist nett ei nett ei ist doch garantiert
java monitoring oder sowas das ist moment das ist was von denen moment warum
soll ich schon erfahrungen haben mit software die die für sie von ihnen
hergestellt wird damit hat auch niemand erfahrung es sei denn der arbeitet schon
da
ernsthaft interne software in den stellen beschreibung wir hatten damit erfahrung
ab dynamics das kenne ich kann es nicht mehr ganz zu und das kenne ich aber das
sagt mir was
oracle monka es was was haben sie eigentlich alle immer nur mit oracle
db oracle vr oracle vr das benutzt jemand ok ich werde euch jetzt mal
massive lizenzbedingungen von oracle erklären was oracle ist nämlich was das
angeht also massivstes massivstes brain auf auf dieser welt was lizenz
lizenzierung angeht also meine erfahrung mit oracle vr sind folgende
oracle vr sagt richtig aber es es macht nene es ist nicht virtual box gemeint es
ist wirklich oracle vr das gibt es das gibt es das ist in red hat abkömmling
oracle vr kann man gucken ja ok die meines virtual box es gibt ein explizites
oracle vr linux
genau der mute kennt sich aus also die sache ist nämlich folgendes wenn man
eine oracle datenbank virtualisieren will dann hat oracle lange zeit ich weiß
nicht ob das immer noch so ist bei den leute ich sage euch einfach nur wie es
damals gewesen ist hat oracle gesagt ja könnt ihr machen überhaupt kein
problem aber ihr müsst die course des hosts lizenzieren also sprich du hast
eine sx gekauft und was in es gebaut mit 48 kernen da hast du eine vm drauf
gemacht mit vier kernen für deine oracle datenbank und dann hat oracle gesagt
lizenziere doch mal 48 kerne anstatt vier jetzt eigentlich ist eigentlich
richtig so ist immer noch so und darauf hin hat oracle dann gesagt aber aber
wenn ihr oracle virtualisieren wollt dann nehmt doch unsere virtualisierung
lösung weil mit unserer virtualisierung lösung da müsst ihr nur die kerne
bezahlen die ihr wirklich verwendet also im prinzip machen die das was microsoft
früher ein bisschen mit dem internet explorer gemacht hat die nutzen so ihre
stellung in dem gebiet aus um anderen scheiß von sich zu zählen
so wie der party genau also das ist die oracle taktik so und wir hatten das auch
eine weile wir hatten das auch eine weile und leute das ist richtig schlecht
alle course aller host lizenziert werden ja die haben dachschaden
was ernsthaft fun fact gibt white paper für sx da ja mit esx online migration
über cluster möglich ist musst du nicht nur den ganzen esx host nicht nur den
klasse und die ganze umgebung in einem wie center ja ganz ehrlich ich verstehe
nicht warum es heute immer noch leute gibt die neue sachen mit oracle machen
diese scheiße hier ganz ehrlich wäre für mich also wenn ich wenn ich den kram
planen müsste was ich zum glück nicht machen würde wäre für mich der erste
grund warum ich sagen würde schmeiß weg den scheiß aber es gibt halt noch
genug bestehenden sachen weil mal ganz im ernst kann oracle wirklich
wirklich irgendwas was zwingend notwendig ist in der heutigen zeit was du
nicht mit anderen datenbanken machen kann ich mein klar hat oracle sicherlich
irgendwas ganz abgedrehtes was nur oracle kann aber gerade wenn ich irgendeine
postkreis nehmen oder so ich meine die meisten sachen sind web anwendungen da
da reicht theoretisch theoretisch daten auf der festplatte aus als datenbank
sq light wenn da nicht viele gleichzeitig geräte drauf kommen
weil viele kunden weil viele kunden auf oracle bestehen ja ok das kann sein
otto jobs mache ich mache ich gucke ich mir an
oracle apex sagt mir nix apex ist für mich das ea battle royale ok otto deutscher
otto lan ok die seite ist schon mal gut die job seite ist schon mal poggers
aha
kommt man die seite leht nur wenn ich refresche legt das an meinem ad block
kurator eil nicht da wird überhaupt nichts geprockt der block nichts von der
seite der block aber gar nichts null block ok er block nichts aber block doch
alles klar sehr gut meistens add-on gut job ok deine karriere bei otto schüler
innen studier innen
gibt's kann man da berufserfahrene zur seite du otto also autos weg zur digitalen
transformation das ist pains jam das ist pains jam ich weiß nicht ob wir uns das geben sollen
sekunde ich bin tim aus dem plattform team und wir gestalten die
geschäftsmodell transformation von otto das bedeutet die was und wir gestalten
die geschäftsmodell transformation von otto die geschäftsmodell transformation das
heißt von katalog zur online oder oder wie das bedeutet wir entwickeln otto vom
händler zur plattform weiter das heißt sie machen marketplace anstatt dass sie
selbst verkaufen arbeiten wir gar nicht in festen prozessen das heißt wir haben
täglich wechselnde aufgaben wir arbeiten nicht in festen prozessen zu gut deutsch
wir haben eigentlich keine ahnung was wir machen sagen aber wir sind furchtbar
agil in beratender funktion für den vorstand unterwegs mal sprechen wir mit
kollegen über einzelne projekte oder setzen teams auf die die transformation
das haben wir auch leute das haben wir jetzt auch seit neuestem ich war jetzt in
korona zeiten jetzt ein bisschen weniger benutzt sie haben jetzt bei uns auch
manche manche büros an der ecke manche büros an der ecke haben sie geräumt und
haben da jetzt einfach in schreibtisch reingestellt und haben gesagt hier das
ist der think tank das heißt wenn du also du kannst nicht denken und sobald du da
reingehst wirst du absolut six hat
bei uns sind allerdings die klasse wir haben keine klasse schreiben wo man
durchgucken kann was auch ganz gut ist weil ich ich kann ich kann nicht gucken
wenn ich wenn ich beobachtet werde nicht denken wenn ich beobachtet werde weiß
wie es euch geht und das sink tank ja den haben wir auch bei uns jetzt am start
das ist aber auch erforderlich weil ansonsten die großraum büros am start
sind da kann man nicht gescheit denken oder andere leute zu nerven also wenn man
das mit mehr machen übrigens was wisst ihr wisst ihr was die da drinne gerade
nicht machen was die art die denken definitiv da gerade nicht die machen
irgendwelche daily keine ahnung post-its an die wand kleben
auf die die transformation gestalten ich habe hier häufig die mögliche so sehen
keine leute aus die denken er denkt vielleicht er denkt vielleicht der
denkt sich gerade ich habe keinen bock auf den scheiß so sieht er aus gerade
bekommen was machen die ich muss lesen was auf dem was steht aber steht aber
steht auf dem fernseh seck seck marken image des kunden ah ok hat mit artie
schon mal nichts zu tun geht mir fort ne das ist kein kann man bord an der wand
da müsstest du mir wobei moment vielleicht ist das doch ein highly
agile kann man bord muss man mal schauen aber eher eher nicht
naja gut das könnte alles sein normalerweise müsstest du beim kann man
bord oben verschiedene kategorien stehen haben und dann schiebst du also in dem
kann man bord hängen hast du verschiedene kategorie also verschiedene
status und die das müsste eigentlich schon voll mit posted sein dass du sie
dann verschieben kannst
ein abgearbeitetes kann man bord also mein so was was ist in der realität in
der form so wahrscheinlich nicht geben wir das ist ich glaube das ist ehrlich
gesagt wenn man mal genau sich überlegt nichts von beidem sondern das ist was
einfach dahingestellt für werbezwecke für das video ja ja guck ich mir gleich
an 9 1 2 0 2 ist das irgendein hex code oder so oder es ist random face roll
über die tastatur ich habe hier häufig die möglichkeit
bekommen ideen die ich hatte auch wirklich in die tat umzusetzen und so
sind es schon viele was was was was agenda moment ich will wissen was
er hat werner werner otto zitate a agentur oder sowas
agenda das heißt agenda agenda werner otto zitate
berth und gesch
gegangen wo kunden das ganze erleben konnten uns feedback geben konnten und
das hat mich auch schon wahnsinnig stolz gemacht die welt und die technologie
ändert sich täglich und mein anspruch ist es dass wir mit otto in fünf jahren
ein unternehmen sind dass diese veränderten technologien und lösungen so
einsetzen kann dass für unsere kunden ein tolles erlebnis entsteht
alles klar oder auch nicht was haben sie denn hier zu bieten im it bereich new
work die vision ist ein flexibles und vernetztes arbeiten das durch eine
aktive und eigentlich fand ich selbstgestaltung der arbeitsorganisation
sowie ein übergreifendes arbeiten geprägtes social spaces des des sharing
gibt es wirklich leute die desk sharing mögen sinktanks fördern das
kollaborative arbeit ja super super agile moderne junge dynamische leute
mögen wahrscheinlich das schenken
wisst ihr es gibt ja ich bin kein also ich könnte keinen handwerklichen
beruf ausüben das das ist nicht so meine welt aber eine
sache eine sache mag ich bei handwerkern da gilt es ja schon quasi fast
als ja fast schon als fast schon so schlimm als wäre mit der eigenen frau
fremd gegangen wenn einer den den werkzeugwagen des anderen anfasst
und und das finde ich und das finde ich ehrlich gesagt bei schreibtischen und
arbeitsplätzen eh ganz gut wenn mein zeug keiner angreift die sollen einfach
alle die finger weg lassen und gut ist ok wo gibt es denn jetzt hier jetzt hier
ohne jobs für berufserfahrende senior project manager gut das ist definitiv
nix für uns
wir setzen bei was war ich schreibt wir setzen bei uns in der arbeit mobile
arbeitsplätze um original jeder hockt das ist bei uns auch so das ist bei
uns auch so wir haben auch mobile arbeitsplätze also sprich wir haben
also wir haben nur noch ein notebook auf der arbeit das kann man theoretisch
überall einklipsen das haben wir aber schon seit drei vier jahren so ich hab
das vielleicht zweimal gemacht und im prinzip ist jeder da hocken geblieben
wo er vorher auch hocken geblieben ist das ist richtig schlimm guck ich mir
klar jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal otto an und danach gucken wir uns das hier an
das sollte ich mir nämlich laut laut chat auch anschauen
muss mir das immer kurz hier wo war deutsche otto da ist mal kurz markieren
bei uns gibt es immer ein wettrennen um die plätze mit geiler aussicht
bei uns nicht bei uns nicht bei uns jetzt jeder dort wo er sonst aussitzt gut
jetzt aktuell sitzt eh keiner da sondern sind alle daheim
ich weiß nicht vielleicht nehme ich morgen schon auf wenn wir heute viele
gute sachen finden es hat jeder arbeitsplatz noch noch einen noch einen
ein kraft was sind es 30 zoll oder so aber nachdem alle den gleichen namen
kannst du dich alle überall mit dem notebook einstecken
ok was haben was haben wir denn bei otto zu bieten
controller für mich ist ein controller was was ich in pce express slot stecke
aber die verstehen da wahrscheinlich was anderes drunter it business analyst
projekt kann man das kann man das filtern das ganze bvl zeug juckt mich
nicht tätigkeitsfeld it jawoll hamburg ja meinetwegen
jetzt haben wir es interne buchhaltung da irgendwas muss er ja kontrollieren
aber hamburg weg macht aber es gibt nur hamburg ok im business analyst software
developer ja war business to business accounting und payment ok das ist das
halt was sie gesagt haben ein senior defops das ist wie gemacht für mich das
gucken wir uns klar an business analyst business analyst technical design lied
software developer ja war specialist linux automatisierung plattform
defops services exquisite boar die haben aber ganz schön viel solar sucht
manche index such index zeug search engineer da ist er endlich ein master
das interessiert mich was man als agila meister macht das ist wie gemacht für
mich ja ich ein master den gucken wir uns jetzt an
agile master team aufbau entwicklung und begleitung hört sich ein bisschen an wie
sterbehilfe so von von von der aufmachung ja teamentwicklung und
begleitung ok agile master als agile als alt das kann man doch nicht mal lesen
als agile master team was der satz ergibt doch schon keinen sinn als agile
master team organisieren und begleiten wir die ach so ah das ist das team wo
du dann reinkommst also das ist ein team von agilen meistern ok begleiten wir den
aufbau die weite unserer cross funktionalen produktentwicklung steams in
der otto logistik wir sehen uns dabei in der bla bla bla an eigenverantwortliche
produktentwicklung zu führen dabei zu unterstützen dass die teams übergreifen
in otto wertströmen mehr wert für unsere kundin was genau macht ihr was sagt uns
das ich verstehe es wirklich nicht was machen die also ich glaube die hätten
keine zwei weniger aussagekräftigen setze reinschreiben können für die
erklärung was sie denn machen das sind leute die sich team events ausdenken
dafür machst du dafür brauchst du doch aber kein eigenes team ok vielleicht
die machen so dinge in diese richtung die halten den platzmahn den ganzen tag
den ganzen tag für uns ist ein framework für was für uns ist ein framework wie
scrum oder kanban endlich mal jetzt wird es agil ob die auch safe und eitel
machen was mein dir also ich persönlich bin ja eher fan von safe eitel und
teams scrum und kann man ist aber auch ok
ok also weiter für uns ist ein framework wie scrum oder kann man nicht vorgeschrieben
es doch mal sondern ein mittel zum zweit hey das finde ich gut das machen das
machen das machen viel zu viele so nach dem motto motto in irgendeinem eitel
handbuch steht drin und man muss das so machen also müssen wir das auch so
machen ob das zur firma passt oder nicht ein klassischer bullshit shop ja so
liest sich das für mich auch du sprichst in fremden zungen ich weiß ja
auch nicht was ich da ausspreche ok wir verwenden metoden so wie sie uns
entsprechend hilfreich erscheinen das finde ich aber gut mit dem ziel wirken
wirksamkeit in der produktentwicklung zu schaffen was sie genau machen verstehe
ich aber immer noch nicht wir arbeiten wir gucken uns gleich an was man dafür
braucht wir arbeiten im agil master team an unserem kompetenz aufbau gemäß
unserer stärken unter bedürfnis ok leute was
ich habe wirklich ich also ich ich verstehe die worte aber ich verstehe den
sinn nicht
das ist ungefähr so wie wenn er jemand zuhört der einen vortrag hält
über kanon quanten physik oder so und ihr versteht manche worte und denkt euch
ok das ist ein richtig gültiger deutscher sachs aber ihr versteht einfach nicht
was er sagen will
offenen diskurs konfliktkultur da wir gemeinsam lernen konnte ich verbessern
werden
ok ist eine offene konfliktkultur was gutes ist eine offene konfliktkultur ist
doch alle schau dir aufs maul ja lass draußen um 12 treffen das wäre eine
offene konfliktkultur ich glaube die meinen das aber anders das bringt der job
eins was ist 1 rastri 16 ausgabe only
arbeit in und mit dem produkt entwicklung mentor ach hier kommen wir zum
moment ich denke ich denke man man wie man ist ein master
warum muss ich wie kann ich denn ein master mentoren und coachen wenn ich
selbst ein master bin coach ich mich selbst oder wie man ist dann quasi der
master der age ein masters oder wie
was ein was ein bullshit irgendjemand hat eben geschrieben bullshit shop im chat
genauso liest sich das dann ist dann quasi sehn ja ich ein master
was ein schwachsinn alter ok was was macht was macht man da erfahrung im team
aufbau ok dann die machen team events ja wirklich anscheinend man darf nicht
besser ja das ist ganz böse erfahrung in der moderation unterschiedlicher
medium und workshop formate ausgeprägte kommunikations skills und
bereitschaft agilen metoden und frameworks da bin ich ja der aller der
aller agilste ich habe wirklich keine ahnung was die
man ich immer ganz im ernst ich glaube diese stellenanzeige ist aber von
jemanden geschrieben der auch nicht weiß was die machen
weil ansonsten wird man ja vielleicht irgendwas erkennen was sie denn machen
nice to have
ausgeprägten diese kenntnis und erfahrung zur feedback zu feedback
metoden und im etablieren einer feedback kultur feedback kultur heißt so viel wie
dein change hat es kaputt gemacht du sagst oder oder was
erfahrung erfahrung zu skalierung ansetzen und wertstrom betrachtung das
ist zu 6 hat also wir skalieren prinzipiell eno diagonal ich glaube wisst
ihr was ich glaube mit so einem satz könnte ich da wahrscheinlich echt
punkten wenn ich das in der bewerbung schreibe ich sehe sie sind auf der suche
nach erfahrenen skalierungsexperten könnte man könnte man anfangen ja
irgendwie ich bin erfahrender skalierungsexperte meine spezialität ist
das diagonal skalieren
ich würde mich ja echt gerne einfach nur mal so aus scheiß und mit fake
namen bei sowas bewerben und einfach den größten stuss reinschreiben der mir so
einfällt und mal gucken was ans antwort kommt das machen wir ich schreibe
dass das das waren wir das war im stream beschreiben im stream die
bewerbung aber nicht dass nicht dass das auffällt
ich weiß es ist ja nicht verboten irgendwie mit fake sachen sich zu
bewerben aber der chat muss mir da ein bisschen helfen der chat muss mir ein
bisschen helfen ja erfahrung einer lateralen für was was ist lateral
seitlich die seite betreffend von der seite ausgehend ok erfahrung in einer von
der seite ausgehenden führungsrolle sowie in der agilen softwareentwicklung
was ist denn eine von der seite ausgehenden für uns also quasi man
macht eigentlich nur so man macht gar man macht nichts direkt
sondern man man so von der seitenlinie wieder wieder wieder trainer oder
ein wertschätzendes arbeitsumfeld expert in den know-how
meditiere in unsere meditations
meditiere alles klar trifft deine kolleginnen in unseren social spaces
zieh dich in unsere bibliothek zurück wählen auf dem ganzen campus und new
work machen ist möglich erwähnt wähler warum er warum eigentlich campus das ist
kein ist campus nicht immer irgendwie in der uni eigentlich ja das hat mit
campus überhaupt nichts zu tun
das ist das ist wenn otto google werden will glaube ich dann kommt sowas raus
noch mehr sie bieten noch mehr leute noch mehr es hört gar nicht mehr auf
mitarbeiterrabatt flexible arbeitszeiten kleinsteine hvv ok das ist das ist
hamburg verkehrsverbund oder so guck mal du kannst geld von otto bekommen und
kannst dann wieder bei otto damit bestellen exquisite 30 urlaubstage ok das
ist nicht gesetzlich vorgeschrieben ist aber ziemlich standard mittlerweile
fitness und gesundheit familie und job ja was soll das jetzt bedeuten familie und
job müsste schon konkret werden mobiles arbeiten das ist gut in der
kran in der heutigen zeit ist wichtig dass so was da steht weiter bildung
cross funktionale projekte ich glaube nicht dass es ein benefit für mich ist
software development bei otto das muss ich muss ich mir so angucken dann dann
ist gut mit otto ich sage es euch reicht dann das campus leben die meins echt
ernst das ist keine uni leute das ist das ist ein arbeitsplatz ganz normaler
arbeitsplatz schuster die haben wirklich den schuster
krass warum bestellte den nicht einfach bei otto neue schuh
bewirb dich als schuster suchen sie ja nicht aber vielleicht vielleicht ist man
so agil die leute sind so agil die können auch einfach mit schuster lernen
so social spaces das kollabor rate
groß essensangebot für park ja ok das ist natürlich nicht schlecht wenn man
der autofahrer ist paket job das ist praktisch das ist tatsächlich echt
praktisch wobei ich dafür wenig wenig verwendungszweck hat weil bei uns um die
ecke in frankfurt ist und amazon paket shop kann es direkt an zeug abholen
reinigung das ist auch nicht verkehrt
so wahnsinnig geil und bequem sieht es jetzt nicht aus muss ich ehrlich sagen
leute jetzt weiß jetzt wisst ihr auf warum die dieses sink tanks haben du
hast keine ruhe guck mal das ist großraumbüro großraumbüro wurde ich nicht
konzentrieren kannst
und hier sitzt wahrscheinlich keiner weil sonst der chef durchläuft und sagt
wird er gearbeitet oder geschwätzt
ah es sieht gut aus kantine ist echt ein vorteil für mich ohne scheiß
kantine ist beste ok als nächstes als nächstes kommt der kicker tisch der
darf auch nicht fehlen für alle die meinen sie wollen akil sein
ich wusste es aber der klassiker als nächstes kommt der kicker tisch was hängt da an der wand was ist das seck was hängt da an der wand
warum kann ich das bild nicht aufmachen inspect source ja was gibt's leider was
ist denn das luftluft befeuchte oder irgendwie so was da hat das soll da
er macht elektronisches da das kann tatsächlich sein ja dat hat marcel
scorpion jetzt nicht in da channel ich weiß nicht wie ich jetzt da drauf
komme aber irgendwie es wird es gerade beim thema dat eingefallen
marcel scorpion prostitution pains champ leader von früher ja weiß kennt
keiner mehr das war das war irgendwie der disstrack
damals
kicker tisch
ok äußerst unbequeme bänke die die die die sehen das ist ja überhaupt kein fake
lachen von beiden das ist das ist legit echtes lachen so sieht das immer so aus
wenn ich wenn ich wirklich glücklich bin und lache ja gerade bei ihr sieht das
sehr natürlich aus das lachen
so was haben wir hier sonst noch das ist tatsächlich die einzige bank
die sind super agil hier sauna oder was soll das ach nee das ist der meditationsraum
das ist der meditationsraum
ja ich finde auch optisch ist das echt alles sehr schick gemacht
die sache ist nur die wahrscheinlich wird es nicht so aussehen
das haben die alles so super belicht belichtet und gemacht für den für den
fotograf stellzer
letztendlich sieht man aber auch immer das gleiche was heißt wahrscheinlich
wird das gar nicht so groß sein
auf hier sind sie agil hier sind richtig agil und er kann hier erst mal mit
ich würde sagen hat ist das ein ubuntu mit wishlist studio code nicht ist keine
ubuntu das ist ein winos 10 mit wishlist studio code würde ich sagen
ja ok das chat gibt mir recht perfekt
sieht alles genauso gefakt aus wie ein katalog ehrlich gesagt ich hatte glaube
ich die letzten 15 jahre kein autokatalog mal outlook pains champ gehst mal fort
die chatten gerade miteinander kuck die sind so agil die sitzen im gleichen
raum und chatten miteinander ja es sieht schon nicht schlecht aus
das der meditationsraum exquisite also allein schon allein schon für
pepo fett würde ich würde ich würde ich würde ich mir mal angucken ja und nach
dem man mobil arbeiten kann kann man doch sicherlich auch sich einfach den
ganzen tag in die kafeterie ersetzen oder ich mein wenn man so agil mobil und
diagonal skaliert 24 7 arbeitsplatz in der kantine würde ich sagen
einfach morgens direkt rein in die kantine in die ecke setzen noise
cancelling kopfhörer auf und ab geht der hacker man
ich skaliere dann sogar meinen bauchumfang ja diagonal so weiter noch
mehr kantine
ist das zum essen oder ist es verzierungen
ich würde sagen das ist so basilikum zum essen oder sowas oregano
ja gut also oh das muss man sagen
otto
i love helping create teams we are all sitting in one boat raising the
environment okay das sieht jetzt schon ein bisschen realistischer aus hier als
das was sie da vorher gezeigt haben dass das sieht wenigstens nach normal
arbeitsplatz aus auch wenn hier irgendwie gerade keiner setzt aber das
ist wenigstens normal arbeitsplatz aus hier und die sind richtig agil hier reale
analysen der rest ist fake das hier kommt drauf an probleme wünsche user stories
leute user stories exquisite
engineers can thrive and develop and make use of helping otto move forwards
by the way warum haben die eigentlich so viele sticker das macht man noch viel
besser in einem ticket system das video ist so alt
naja 2018 wo alt ist es jetzt an hat
for developers and otto it's so nice that you can experience different tools
and software
i want to be excited to go to work every morning because i do das sei er aus wie
heute das am tisch das sei er aus wie irgend so eine speed dating veranstaltung
gerade to go to work every morning because i'm doing what i love
we're not just an e-commerce websites anymore and we're really strongly focus
on creating them ernsthaft was für tastaturen
monkeys marketplace where other partners can show their products on our way so
sieht das geschehen aus zwei leute an einem tisch alle thinkpads
sides and that we can provide various other value-added services to them
i can only do what i love if i always feel like challenge and always feel like
learning i never want to stop learning and i think here
jetzt haben sie zu denen gesagt guckt mal besonders interessiert auf eine
notebook ihr werdet dabei gefilmt so you always be self developing and learning
more and that's what i love about it
ok genug genug genug otto jetzt also mal den wollte ich mir noch angucken den
senior devops spezialist genug otto ja nur mal kurz drüber scrollen was wollen
die dann was wollen die dann was wollen die denn als devops spezialist haben
du bildet du run it you own it moment was moment ich das muss ich jetzt
doch mal lernen manchmal manchmal sage ich wörter bevor ich den
satz gedacht habe wozu sie gehören da kommen so schwachsinnige sätze raus wie
eben wir entwickeln direkt auf dem otto kam die
haben es echt mit ihrem campus das hat mit mit uni doch überhaupt nichts zu
tun ich weiß google nennt das auch so aber das
ergibt trotzdem keinen sinn
ich war längere zeit externer dort das video ist wird ist ein witz google mal
otto passion for performance
das ist ja von 2012 otto kippt sap ok sap raus ist ja immer
nicht verkehrt dass vorm passion for performance geriet freilich zum flop
2013 die wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich ist es heute auch nicht besser aber sie
werden wahrscheinlich sagen dass er so die standard anfordert ist bei uns ja
auf der arbeit auch so wenn du sachen wenn du also nicht bei uns auf der
arbeit ist auch oft so ich sag leute das haben wir doch schon mal probiert und
ging in die hose dann heißt es immer ja max das war vor fünf jahren heute sind
wir ganz anders aufgestellt heute ist das gar kein ding meistens geht es dann
aber trotzdem in die hose
ok payments ist einer im was im spannungsfeld der kundinnen der händler
innen der regulator ring und einer vielzahl neue löser entwege alle
kundinnen und händler man kann es auch echt über drei mit dem sternchen kram
das also dass jeder soll sie machen wie sie wollen zur
erreichung dieses ziel investiert otto in blabla blabla durch
zusammensetzung des teams aus produkt ohne im moment
kate was ist das alles guck mal hier sind sie selbst hier sind sie selbst
durcheinander gekommen hier sind sie selbst durcheinander gekommen und
developer innen ist fachwissen ebenso vorhanden wie IT und prozess
expertise zudem werden wir durch ein master unterstützt die tun fast so als
weiß jeder was das ist hätten wir uns nicht die stellenanzeige davon
angeguckt hätten wir keine ahnung und nach der stellenanzeige sind wir
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht schlauer gewesen ok jetzt jetzt kommt drauf an
was wollen sagen bei der gestaltung arbeitsantrag orientieren wir uns stark
an scrum die entwicklung unserer produkte im kontext business to business
accounting und payment folgt dem grundsatz you build it you run it you
own it das heißt ich habe es immer für immer und ewig an der backe doch da
hätte ich keinen bock drauf das heißt die konzeption die entwicklung auch qr
erfolgen vollständig unser team
ja gut das heißt das das heißt ja was anderes als das was da steht also das
was da steht hat mit dem hier nix zu tun
konzeption entwicklung und testen erfolgte in unserem team ja vollkommen
ok aber das ist im prinzip das was die hier schreiben ist eigentlich nur der
teil mit you build it das da ist der teil you build it you run it you own it hat
damit eigentlich nix zu tun
konzeption ist bilden entwickeln ist bilden testen ist im prinzip so
zwischendurch bilden und laufen ja you run it you own it ok passt schon ich
meine die werden schon wissen was sie machen scheint ja ganz gut zu zu flutschen
mittlerweile willst du teil des teams sein bewirb dich so was wollte ich ja
java spring boot ja gut ich glaube das ist tatsächlich ziemlich beliebt und
gar nicht schlecht terraform terraform ist echt nice fargate
kenne ich nicht sagt mir gar nix aws stellt aws bin ich nicht so der huge
expert ehrlich gesagt in keiner klautlösung weil also bei aws kann ich
bedienen google cloud kann ich auch ein bisschen bedienen escher kann ich auch
halbwegs bedienen aber ich würde nicht sagen dass ich der next level klaut
native big brain bin
das ist aber auch schwierig weil die ganzen oberflächen sowohl von aws als
auch von escher die sind so gebaut dass man nicht durchblickt
aurora post das was hat was ist denn aurora post das das kenne ich auch
nicht das ist die amazon ah ja ok dann ergibt es den
hast mir ist google cloud plattform zertifiziert exquisite sns sqs ok es
hat auf s3 das kenne ich wenigstens noch lambda ap geld wäre ok das ist alles
alles aws zeug klaut von prometheus kraft oh leute prometheus und kraft
fahner habe ich euch habe ich euch schon mal gezeigt was ich hier für ein cooles
dashboard für meine heizung gebaut habe da kann ich nämlich sehen die aktuelle
wassertemperatur und den fehlerstatus ich glaube das sollte ich meinen meine
bewerbung da reinschreiben
das da wäre mal eine bewerbung werte
gleich skraf an der sport rausholen elastix hat gett hab action ohne mist also
mit dem kram hier kenne ich mich wirklich auch ok elastix hat nicht so
wirklich mit gett hab actions wo manche aus kraft fahner kenne ich wirklich nicht
schlecht aus terraform ist auch ganz gut leider habe ich keinen plan von java und
spring boot und das ganze aws ökosystem bin ich jetzt auch nicht so gut drin
aber das lernt man ja relativ schnell
warum wollen die dass du spring boot als def obs tut kannst weil die ehrlich
gesagt kein def obs tut wollen sondern einen full stack der komplett full
stackt aber aber jetzt nicht so das was man normalerweise als full stack in
einer anwälter in einer stellenanzeige drin stehen hat die wollen wahrscheinlich
dass du wirklich von der konzeption der anwendung bis zum erstellen der
der der aws resources inklusive dem deployment alles macht also ja du
arbeitest doch hier die event gesteuerte micro service architektur da geht ja
auch allen agilen menschen jetzt einer drauf ab bei dieser kombination event
sourcing nennt sich das ja immer ganz cool event source weil weil school
klingt also im prinzip ist das wahrscheinlich einfach stink normale
message q mit ein paar java programm die da sachen draus lesen und
reinschreiben das klingt natürlich nicht so geil wie event gesteuerte
micro service architektur im prinzip sind ein paar java programme die in
message q sachen rein und rausschreiben aber ist natürlich so besser micro
service architektur gleich spaghettico dann nicht unbedingt oder schön also
von der idee her ist ja beim micro service ist eher so dass die einzelnen
dinger klein und kompakt sind so dass du nicht so anfällig für spaghettico
bist und theorie und praxis gehen natürlich manchmal da ein bisschen
auseinander aber von der theorie sollte das eigentlich ordentlicher sein am ende
sollst du auch noch die toiletten putzen ich erinnere noch mal dran die
haben auch nur schuhe star irgendeiner muss auch die schuhe fixen
doch du arbeitest einem englischsprachigen cross funktionalen
team ok was mastiff mastiff fortgeschrittene terraform kennen sie du
lebst infrastructure as code ich träume in infrastructure as code fundierte
erfahrung das würde ich alles auf die reihe kriegen da da fehlt es bei mir
halt weil wir machen auf der arbeit hauptsache hauptsächlich er und ich
habe privat auch nichts mit aws großartig gemacht bisher ich meine ich habe
dann den account ich bin da eingeladen ich habe da schon mal eine vm angelegt
und so was aber also privat habe ich jetzt ab und zu mal google verwendet aber
hauptsächlich für maps und kleine kleine services und habe dann festgestellt
das ist ganz schön teuer wenn du da viele anfragen machst und auf der arbeit
eigentlich nur azure und für mich persönlich privat verwende ich nur
hetzner wobei hetzner also auch hätte auch das was hetzner klaut sich nennt
kannst du nicht mit aws und azure und google vergleichen im prinzip ist
hetzner klaut ja eigentlich nur eine möglichkeit möglichst easy schnell
stunden stundenweise abgerechnete vms zu erstellen also das steht zwar klaut
dran kann hat er mit aws nichts zu tun aws ist halt viel mehr als vms aws und
auch azure ist ja zum größten teil irgendwelche fertigen services die du
kaufen kannst und jetzt nicht einfach nur vms übrigens wenn ein 20 euro hetzner
gut haben code sucht nur für neukunden by the way kann im chat ausrufe zeichen
hetzner machen und mit meinem code sich einen account erstellen und er kriegt
20 euro startguthaben und mit den 20 euro könnte glaube ich den triple core
server drei vier monate laufen lassen es ist auf jeden fall nicht schlecht wenn
man eh das mal ausprobieren wollte maven und cradle sind nicht unbekannt nein
sie sind mir nicht unbekannt aber ich mag sie auch nicht erfahrung pyson
shell script ja shell script hacker man hier gar kein problem betriebs erfahrung
von monitor habe ich gute englisch kenntnis zur ko da muss ich wieder mal
öttinger zitat rausholen we are all sitting in one boat englisch easy easy
erfahrung mit github actions habe ich erfahrung mit event driven
architekturen ja gut mit näht mit in dem fall mit aws message zu zeuschen
ein habe ich nicht zwei kantine drei kantine in zwei bistros ein foot
what the fuck
die wollen es aber echt wissen ok genug otto
vor mwr suchen so genug otto alles zu hier so ok was soll ich mir jetzt noch
angucken dass der chat hat gesagt da den soll ich mir angucken it welchen denn
hebräisch kust und customer support
englisch englisch und hebräisch in bonn
das ist immer eine mischung ich lese die werbung stimmt it student assistant
eform oi oi 3 hat
if spricht wie spricht wenn die überhaupt aus ein iphone iphone so wie
einer nicht richtig iphone ausbrechen kann iphone die internationale
vereinigung der ökologischen landbaubewegung ok ich sage ja auch immer
es ist nicht wirklich erforderlich dass man sich mit seinem arbeitgeber da
irgendwie tiefgreifen identifiziert solange die pünktlich bezahlen und man
da zufrieden ist ist wurscht was die machen
oder ist ja auf englisch warum soll warum sollte ich mir das denn jetzt durch
angucken
it's an exciting time to join our team
student it assistant
max was ist eigentlich bei einem steffer darf so ein gehalt liegen ja darf ich
habe ich auch letztens im stream schon gemacht und mache ich in dem video auch
noch mal
also sie haben eine meck meck based environment
meck linux server ubuntu 16 18 20 web server
prepare computers for me for for new colleagues ok das im prinzip man richtet
man richtet rechner ein welches ist deine lieblingsdistro desktop oder server
server ubuntu desktop manjarow auf der arbeit verwende ich red hat aber bin ich
nicht so großartig entfernt von you are first level mama noch alles klar pro
active team player
ja was ist denn was ist denn an der stellenanzeige die stellenanzeige sieht
doch relativ normal aus
oder habe ich jetzt irgendwas nicht nicht gesehen
wo steht das gehalt moment oh für 1000 euro pro monat teilzeit na kommt drauf
an moment 1000 euro pro monat heißt ja kommt
darauf an
ist die frage wie viele stunden hier benefit hier steht so 20 stunden die
woche und wenn das ist das ist das ist das ist genau halbzeit na das ist dann
aber doch ein bisschen wenig
was ist dann doch ein bisschen wenig
leute wie ist das so ich habe von studenten jobs keine ahnung sagt man ist
das gut oder nicht gut
der versteuern muss es ja immer in frankfurt kriegst du dafür einen döner
es gibt ein großer döner ok also anscheinend so ganz ganz ok eher eher
nicht so toll eher auf den niedrigen also niedrig bis ok ok verstehe naja ja so
aber so schlimm ist die stellenanzeige doch jetzt gar nicht ja du musst noch
versteuern salesforce eget ok next linux konsultant das sollte ich mal noch
angucken hat jemand geschrieben linux konsultant mwd standort full da das kann
ich so weit weg
arbeitsbereiche beratung und implementierung einstieg als linux
konsultant start datum sofort arbeitszeit vollzeit also als konsultant
ist ja schon mal wieder richtig pence champ also das heißt die suchen jemand
der sich auskennt mit linux die suchen ein den sie verschachern können oder
muss her an der wehr nice prime subscription huge ab iq plus plus für den
chat beratung implementierung konfiguration und integration einer et
infrastruktur lösung die auf dem open source monitoring pro nagios moment in
welchem jahr sind wir sind wir sind wir sind wir 1999 oder so
wir sind tatsächlich 2021 also wenn 2001 gewesen oder oder 2011 2011 2011
hätte ich mir noch irgendwie gefallen lassen am rande am rande aber jetzt
nagios wird doch noch oft genutzt ja meistens nur bei irgendwelchen pence
pence champion ich persönlich mag nagios ja also wenn ihr mich fragt ich habe
immer ein herz für nagios gab das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran dass ich
früher mal relativ viel nagios selbst gemacht habe ich weiß nicht ob ich die
konfig noch aus dem schlaf könnte aber ich habe früher ziemlich viel nagios
selbst gemacht ich habe ein herz für nagios aber ansonsten ich sehe es so
gerade also selten das ist auch selten dass es in stellens anstatt stellen
anzeigen drin steht also bei uns auf der arbeit ist es eine mischung bei uns ist
das auch nicht gerade gut gelöst ja also wir haben eine ganz wilde wilde mischung
das ist aber historisch gewachsen also wir haben zum größten teil zappix zappix
ist aber von der web vom web interface wirklich huge pence champ und ansonsten
die modernen super agilen event gesteuerten micro services falls wir so
was haben dann ist das mit prometheus und grafana und teilweise mit elastic
surge und kibana gemacht
als weltweites unternehmen von diskauer nutzt nagios sehr intensiv das kenne ich
dass er ja gut kippa xy dann weiß ich ja auch von wem du redest weil ich weiß
wo du vorher warst ja gut aber die haben wahrscheinlich dort die nagios
installation auch schon 20 jahre oder so ganz ehrlich ich würde es bei uns auch
verstehen wenn wir nagios hätten angenommen wir hätten nagios schon
im einsatz gehabt und hätten da 5000 systeme drin warum sollte man das
ändern das ist bei denen wahrscheinlich auch so
so open source ticket request system otrs ist otrs nicht mittlerweile out of
lager end of life ich habe da doch irgendwas gelesen letztens ist das nicht
end of life
ja anscheinend nicht ne das ist ein ticket das ist ein ticket system
und eine cmdb i do it oh das klingt nach einer software die man nicht verwenden
will so leute so business software mit solchen
namen sind meistens ganz furchtbar schrecklich die lösung für alti
dokumentations oje oje die 360 grad alti dokumentation oje so software kenne ich
die ist pains jam hoch 10 tom hat als alti administrat alle hände zu tun er
muss eine vielzahl von prozessen in seiner firma im auge behalten sein
derzeitiges alti dokumentation system hilft das hat der chef selbst aufgenommen
oder das hat der chef selbst aufgenommen dabei nicht wirklich
tatsächlich scheint es ihm nur noch mehr arbeit zu machen
wir von i do it sind hier um zu helfen unser alti dokumentations system hilft
tom dabei seine daten in verwertbare informationen zu verwandeln
bei pfeiffer eingekauft das system kann ohne externe unterstützung installiert
und an die bedürfnisse eines unternehmens angepasst werden
mithilfe unserer 360 das ist minders auli 100 pro ein vollständigen überblick
über seine IT prozess während unsere schnittstellen dafür sorgen das ist
minders auli dass informationen aus anderen systemen reibungslos in die
dokumentation einfließen können tom ist erstaunt wie viel erfahrung in die
entwicklung des systems eingeflossen ist und doch ist i do it für sein
mittelständisches unternehmen immer noch sehr kostengünstig
tom ist begeistert er hat jetzt ein er sieht auch wahnsinnig begeistert aus was
sucht mal nach aterra werbung tatsächlich hilft und tauben es nicht
alleine warum hat er überhaupt eine drohne im büro die darum fliegt
unternehmen setzen i do it bereits ein möchten sie ihre IT dokumentation auch
vereinfachen dann laden sie aber nicht mit i do it kostenlose testversuche
aterra werbung was soll ich suchen danach oder 35.000 views
idiot schatz i do it
nee das ist irgendwas anderes da muss bald streichst es muss mir
raussuchen was du meinst ok ich muss jetzt suchen
das ist wenn das only leute ach du scheiße ja ja ja so so software
kenne ich keeper xy das sieht fast aus wie unser du weißt was ich meine oder
unser f fängt mit f an und hört mit t auf
sieht fast genauso schlimm aus
das ist eine software die will ich nicht benutzen
nein moment ich weiß mit was das gemacht ist das ist pings wie heißt
dieses javascript zeug mit diesen das ist so ein uraltes das ist doch browser
das ist doch im browser wie heißt dieses uralte javascript
ding wo die batten so aussehen gs back ne ex ex ex gs kann das sein
ne das kann ja ex ex gs gibt es so was ja das da ist es glaube ich
das ist
das ist aber dann sieht es nicht aus ich glaube das ist ex gs so was ganz so
was ganz altes hässliches da sehen die standard batten so aus ich glaube das
ist ich glaube das ist ex gs richtiger pain richtiger pains champ wir sind
ein paar stellen anzeigen ja so sieht doch proxmox auch aus ja wahrscheinlich
verwenden das gleiche
ok das ist nichts was ich oh je oh je oh je wenn ich so wenn ich so software
sehe da kriege ich anfälle guckt euch das mal an ok moment was was soll ich
mal gucken das da
msp was was ist denn msp most sucking professionals in one easy to use and
affordable remote monitoring and management solution with the tera
microsoft go to graded it tool suite remote monitoring and management remote
access patch management helpdesk in ticketing as micro reports and so much
more click below to discover a tera today and start monitoring unlimited
devices within minutes ja das konnte nagios auch schon unlimited
might not include na ja geht doch eigentlich weil ich will es nicht
unbedingt verwenden so hier also i do it soll man kennen und in komplexen und
heterogenen altilandschaften eingesetzt wird alles klar ok bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla implementierung und kundensupport vor ort ok ich bin raus leute und tschüss
macht's gut das werden wir nicht sehen diese
kenntnisinteressen bringt somit sehr gute die luktskenntnisse ok also hier da
könnt ihr schon mal hin erfahrung mit monitoring tools wie nagios xt das ist ja
im prinzip nagios bloß ein bisschen moderner deshalb kenne ich mich auch mit
aus wobei ich sagen muss meine nagios kenntnisse sind schon ganz lang her aber
ich denke mal so viel hat sich da nicht getan ich komme da schnell wieder rein
erfahrung mit ticketsystem wie otrs oder kicks was ist denn kicks ticket
system vor meine güte die haben aber schon ganz schön den hang zu crap
software hier oder
warum verwendet man an sowas
dreckig ja nein please das ist so alt dass sie nicht
immer auflöse nicht mal hoch aufgehörte screen obelis ist es direkt runter geht
sofort monka virus ok das ist schon mal nix
du hast erste erfahrung es gehört api schrittstellen ja gut wer hat es nicht
geringe reisebereitschaft im deutschen deutschsprachigen raum was soll
geringe reisebereitschaft heißen das heißt ich habe keinen bock zu reisen im
deutschsprachigen raum die meinen glaube ich eher dass ich nicht oft reisen muss
aber trotzdem ab und zu quasi gezwungen werde so nach dem motto guckt ihr mal
das ticketsystem tanz an ok warum gibt es eigentlich so viele ticketsystem
und warum sind so viele davon müll ok mal gucken wie das hier was bin ich da
sehend was ist das
auch sogar ein werbevideo guckt euch das mal hier ich habe hier ein ticket
vorbereitet ich lache nicht über den akzent sondern über die über die optik
von dem ding bei dem wir ein dativ update installieren sollen was ist das
denn ja meine güte ist normal wie in tanz üblich unsere leistung hier haben
wir zum beispiel drei stunden gebraucht ach du große scheiße
wir haben die leistungsart software installation gemacht
wir buchen es auf das ticket und was ist das für den ui auch dann gleich fertig
ab ok also um jetzt mal irgendwie in den vergleich vergleich zu zu zu finden
das sieht schlechter aus als manche open source guise die man unser linux 2010
verwendet hat also
wir geben aus techniker sicht die zeit frei und erstellen die rechnung ich
meine dafür ist es wenigstens performen hoffe ich mal die abrechnung hier über
die drei stunden also in dem fall 240 euro die rett das tanz raus das wird
ja das sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein altes php forum die zeit wurde sauber
gebucht innerhalb unseres gehört es auch noch dabei im haus waren haben wir noch
mehrere einstellungsmöglichkeiten will mehrere alles ist abheben gebucht also
mich hier auf den hohen kap von srp keine ahnung aber es bestätigt wieder alles
was ich von srp so denke wenn ich das sehe die artikelnummer und die spiel
boar das sieht ja grausam aus das sieht aus wie das sieht wirklich aus wie eine
settings page von einem alten php forum ok wir sind mal fair wir sind mal fair
wir gucken wir gucken mal rein wie es aktuell aussieht wir gucken wir das man
ist ein video das schon bisschen ok leute das sieht das sieht moderner aus das
sieht jetzt moderner aus übrigens eine sache die ich auch nicht verstehe ist
warum ask for demo warum habt ihr nicht einfach eine fertige demo seite ganz im
ernst das verstehe ich nicht die hürde ist so hoch überlegt euch mal wenn ihr
die auswahl habt zwischen dem produkt wo es eine demo gibt und ihr könnt einfach
drauf gucken die hürde dort anzufragen wenn ich hier dieses bild rum zappeln
seh die ist viel zu hoch
sie mail adresse die walten oder oder ist das produkt so schlecht dass es dass
man da kein kein demo machen will
ok leute das sieht guitech nicht echt so aus das sieht nicht schöner aus das
sieht das sieht immer noch genauso schlecht aus wie in dem video
let's go let's go ich will einfach nur wissen wie es aussieht
modules so ist das boah ne das sieht immer das sieht wirklich das sieht
jetzt aus wie ein nagios das sieht aus wie ein alter nagios vor allem warum
schafft man nicht noch nicht mal ordentlich hochauflösende screenshots
pains jam was für software nee das ist outlook oder nee ich weiß ich will es gar nicht
weiter sehen wie auch immer das vorgeschlagen hat mein
beilad wenn ihr damit arbeiten muss guckt ihr mal das hier an weil ich kann
jetzt nicht 30 milliaren ticket system angucken die meisten sind grausam
sylatech selfer
das ist eine wpf anwendung oder das ist eine wpf anwendung wo einer auf outlook
von 1900 oder von 2005 machen wollte da wollte eine outlook aus 2005 nachmachen
aber hauptsächlich aber hauptsache musterkunde eins und zwei ist da
warum warum warum warum benutzt man solche software überhaupt
ich meine da drüber machst du auch keine teile zeugs alter gibt es gibt so allen
crap der immer noch verwendet wird der wahnsinn ist echt der wahnsinn
sucht man nach irgendwas mit pf mit sap haben wir doch so gerade angeguckt
niklas sagt musste man mit tanz arbeit naps gehasst und dann kam noch von der
chef etage der spruch wir tanzen hier alle pains jam ok also alles klar passt
du bist bei uns genau richtig wenn du hoch motiviert agil da fühlen wir uns
sowas von wohl sympathisch engagiert empathisch und fachlich herausragend
ist es gibt so ein paar sachen die gehen oftmals nicht zusammen also leute die
besonders empathisch sind sind meistens fachlich nicht herausragend und leute
die das hier zusammen sind meistens nicht engagiert und wenn sie das alles
zusammen sind sind sie meistens nicht sympathisch ich glaube das gibt es in
kombinationen sehr selten
bla bla bla du dir eine attraktive und leistungsgerechte vergütung wünscht
ja haut mal sagt mal sagt mal was sache ist du wärt auf eine ausgewogene work
life balance und ein angenehmes klima unter kollegen legst ja da lege ich
tatsächlich wert drauf zu unseren vielfältigen wichungskern und der
moment da steht ja überhaupt nichts warum ich wirklich zu was ist denn jetzt
möglich der anreiz dahin zu gehen wir bieten die kaffee das ist ja absolut
nichts sagen what the fuck das ist wirklich komplett nichts sagen
dieses ding homeoffice nach absprache flexible arbeit mit arbeiterevents nein
nein da überzeugt dir mich nicht damit überzeugt dir mich nicht
modernes büro inklusive parkmöglichkeit das finde ich tatsächlich gut dass so
was dasteht ist ja nicht selbstverständlich
okay man darf man darf kostenlos was trinken gesundheitstag langweilig
weg i do it moment haben die jobs bei i do it über uns jobs jawoll wir
bewerben uns bei i do it jetzt react frontend developer meint dieses hässliche
dinges mit react gemacht oder bring ich jetzt durcheinander
ich finde es sieht nicht nach einem modernen react frontend aus um ehrlich zu
sein aber ok ich meine klar du erkennst anhand der optik nicht ob es mit react
ist oder nicht ist mir schon klar aber es sieht nicht modern genug aus
eigentlich dafür gut
wahrscheinlich für die webseite ist die mit react die ist alternat
die meinen nicht den job die meinen was anderes das ist kein das ist keine
react anwendung würde ich sagen dann würde man das hier nicht alles sehen
das wäre javascript inline kram das ist irgendwas keine ahnung front page
aber voll auch guck mal die suche ein full stack develop das ist doch was für uns
zeig mal her
voll stack developer so i do it für tanz suchen die auch welche moment da
müssen wir jetzt auch mal kurz gucken tanz sucht jobs deck da müssen wir gleich
nachschauen unternehmen jobs
da stand was mit admin im code wirklich
es ist in den wordpress kram
ist das normal dass man auf admin ordner referenziert wp admin admin ist das
password
wartet mal
wartet mal null
ok das ist ja noch normal
aber atmen atmen atmen atmen wartet mal atmen atmen ok atmen 123 456 so würde
ich machen okay nein nein nein es ist auch spaß also ich werde mich jetzt auch
nicht ist das eigentlich normal dass man da von außen drauf kommt ist das normal
dass man eigentlich von draußen sollte das nicht irgendwie gesperrt sein
zumindest zumindest mit irgendeiner ht axis oder so und basic aus davor oder
sonst was also leute wenn das jetzt schon hacker man ist wenn ich vier von hand
vier weiß verbreitete passwörter eingebe dann weiß ich auch nicht dann
haben wir echt andere probleme
vollkommen normal ja ok wenn das vollkommen normal ist finde ich aber die
normalität in wordpress doof
schau mal nach defops cloud ops stellen bei lean mal bei was
schau mal defops cloud ops stellen wie heißen die momenti kenn ich das sagt
mir irgendwas meinst du die hier
und die sind die sehen äußerst agil aus schon produkte unternehmen jobs karriere
ok wir lassen all du jetzt mal in ruhe wir machen wir lassen all du jetzt mal
in ruhe und das haben wir ganz schön viele hier am start ok weiter
hockett wie sind wir denn dahin jetzt gekommen
von tanz von tanz immer zu hock zu hock it de hock it.de gekommen
wir bei hock hack it ok was haben wir so? offene stellen
ja eigentlich nix spannendes dabei gucken wir mal die azubi stelle ob da
ne das sieht alles relativ normal aus
sieht eigentlich
ich finde das sieht normal aus
so was haben wir jetzt als nächstes der java mage
java mage also ich bin eher so der rockstar developer paid relocation
can't wait in der aktuellen home office zeit was für spells hat die java mage
klasse das müssen wir echt mal für den pg was
erstellen ob obfos skating stels haben die haben die als spell auf jeden fall
garbage collector spell und huge huge ram auslastung polymorph polymorph haben
die ja das ist gut also wir haben sie hier stuttgart an der akademie zu
remoting jetzt wollen die auch noch lustig sein
ok ok es wird pains champig leute ich sage es euch es wird es wird gringy an
der akademie akademie zu remotingen wurdest du einer der intelligent java
mages des bärenreichs poininger ausgewählt das ist schlimm das ist
schlimm ich krieg bauchschmerzen wenn ich das
lese aber jetzt nicht weil ich lachen muss oder so was pains champ ist dich
einem besonderen und delikaten thread zu widmen und wie lag geht denn das ach du
scheiße hat er gar nicht mehr auf unlängst beschädigte eine der jüngeren
adepten die pipeline zur container stadt kooper nicht das ist ja ganz ganz
schrecklich zu allem unheil mit einem allzu leicht fertig gesprochen
kontinuiert auf nein ich kann es nicht lesen das geht nicht ist ich kann nicht
weiterlesen funktioniert nicht da hat einer zu viel harry potter sich
angeguckt hier und uns und zu viele billige
dann sind dragon sessions gemacht mit keinem gescheiten dungeon master dabei
oder so harry potter trotz der klaren einweisung alles das ist das ist
wirklich ok wir überspringen den ersten absatz mal im stahl der akademie
sattelst du das schnelle rost cradle und da deine mehr maven etwas in die jahre
gekommen ist den schnellen ritt nach kooper näht es nicht innerhalb eines
sprints performen kann alles klar die timeline drängt und du
musst dich wirklich springbooten moment ich lasse das mal eingeblendet das kann
man für den für die ganze zeit dalassen
trotzdem bist du froh dass dich ein team aus treuen mitstreitern begleitet und du
dich der wohl größten herausforderung als java mage nicht alleine stellen
musst skeletal der weise tech romanzer der
ersten stunde und gilt meister von infrastrukturs reitet zu deiner rechnung
klappt auf meine fresse ist es auf grün klar wird ihr auf full stack warrior aus
leidenschaft mit seinem legendären breitscheuer dedos auf dem rücken ich
muss sagen nachdem man das schon mal eine weile wenn man das jetzt eine weile
gelesen hat dann dann man gewöhnt sich dran also das pains champion hört dann
irgendwann auf wie immer verwegen knapp vor dir zu seiner linken hinter euch eine
nur schwer zu estimatende anzahlen an frontend art schon scrum dwarfs und
mason mason eri clerics
während das heute akademie im stellen gelobt verlaßt holst du dir an eine
aufgang als gerecht ok hier ist jetzt das ist die normale das ist die
noch auf alle stellenanzeige wahrscheinlich was in mason ich weiß
nicht mason ist ein bildsystem ich weiß aber nicht ob die das meinen das ist
mason ok dann weiß ich nicht was es sein soll
mein cleric sind meistens heiler aber das wollen sie uns glaube ich nicht hier
mit mitteilen zusammen mit einem team wirkst du
wertschöpfende zauber erstellt entwirft und entwickelt kunden zentrierte und
moderne artefakte für eine für einen bereich der magischen handlungsplattform
handelsplattform des bären reichsbäume ok man hat so eine grobe idee was du
machen sollst ich glaube das wäre der traum für so alle
realer wie wie heißen die leute lab oder diese live action real life roll
player typen gehabt euch wohl seht ein mächtiger zauberer er steht mit dem
feuer im bunde da kannst du bestimmt voll punkten
mit cap zum vorstellungsgespräch ja
dabei trägst du und deine mitscher die vollständigen verantwortung über die
spaß ok was war kubernetes gedürntes kubernetes saß macht man mit deinem mit
ach dachte ich dachte mit dem war hier haben sie es verpasst hier haben sie es
verpasst hier hätten sie reinschreiben sollten mit
deinen gett majors das wäre doch mal was
das wäre noch mal richtig big break jetzt aber das mit majors gett majors
viel besser gewesen gett majors von scrum dwarfs mason reichs die
verantwortung das beschweren und beteuren der ux ferries gehört dabei auch
zu den seien du verlässt die akademie regelmäßig auf magie
java kotlin skala ok no sql gedürntes kubernetes du bist ein agiler team
player
produkt organ alles klar ok ok leute wenn man das sieht wenn man sich da
erst mal dran gewöhnt hat ist es gar nicht mehr so pence champion es ist
natürlich sehr schwierig zu erkennen was die genau jetzt wollen aber moment
dazu gibt es ein video dazu gibt es nicht wirklich ein video oder
monat s 9 the head of product
oh hallo ich habe dich noch gar nicht erwartet lasst mich eine geschichte
erzählen an der akademie zu remotingen würdest du einer der intelligent java
majors aber das ist auch das gleiche der ließ den der ließ den gleichen kram
jetzt noch mal vor des bärenreichs bräuninger ausgewählt
ich einen besonderen und dedikaten thread zu widmen
ja immerhin immer genau immerhin bleiben sie dann ziehen sie das durch ja ok
es ist es ist ziemlich es ist ziemlich pence jam aber ich muss sagen es ist
wenigstens kreativ jetzt mal frage an euch ausgehen noch weiter mal frage an
den chat wir machen mal eine abstimmung
wir machen mal eine abstimmung würdet ihr euch da bewerben oder nicht
bewerben fragezeichen ja nein
schauen wir mal
mit was verdienen die denn ihr geld was machen die überhaupt
das habe ich nicht gecheckt was machen die eigentlich fashion und lifestyle
das ist ein kaufhaus ich habe ehrlich gedacht weil die was von bären und
preu ich habe das wäre irgendwie bierhersteller oder so ok 50 50 also
einige von euch spricht das anscheinend an ok finde ich interessant ich muss
euch ehrlich sagen so schlimm finde ich das jetzt gar nicht ich fand es am
anfang schon enorm kringig und pence jam pick aber man gewöhnt sich dran und es
ist auf jeden fall kreativ
arbeiten mit neuesten technologien ein team innovative projekte agile kultur
neue top notch büros urlaubs- und weihnachtsgeld mit arbeiterrahmen deluxe
kantine der johltest den gibt es noch finde ich cool
einmal das ist deck auf afro ja die haben den zwangsweise eingebaut die
haben den an die haben den zwangsweise eingebaut den wie heißt der typ noch
mal joules splonsky oder so das ist ein blogger der ein relativ viel gelesenes
software entwicklungsblock hatte vor zehn jahren also ich habe keine ahnung
ob das ob es den überhaupt noch gibt joules der da das ist ein recht viel
gelesenes blog gewesen früher ja und er hatte mal in einem seiner blog post
drüber geschrieben so anhand welchen kriterien er so arbeitgeber bewerten
würde aber das ist deck auf afro die haben das dann irgendwie aufgegriffen
source control once der bild daily bild back back database specksquad
quiet work conditions das ist tatsächlich wichtig das haben wir bei
dem letzten nicht gehabt wo war denn das bei otto war das otto hat
in großraumbüros und und krach gehabt best tools that money can buy testers
code screening halloway use helway ist das nicht der flur was ist denn der flur
usability test
ist das nicht der flur ja hier full stack war die meinen das auch noch ernst
die haben für die andere dinge auch so stellen anzeigen der full stack war ja
cobalt monka es ist hier haben sie den java mage drin
ok weg weg genug so was soll ich jetzt gucken hier karriere
das haben sie aber gut gemacht dass die alle blaue sachen an haben oder blau
tut außer außer er erstichter wieder voll raus und ja er hat aber die anderen
haben alle so blaue dinge an wahrscheinlich haben die gesagt zieht
euch was blaues an für das foto
wenn die sich so mühe geben finden die sonst keinen mehr ich würde das nicht
als negativ interpretieren wenn sich einer mühe gibt mit mit den
stellen anzeigen ist doch gut und wahrscheinlich haben die wirklich
schwierigkeit in leute zu finden generell ist es schwierig geworden
leute zu finden aktuell und die letzten jahre schon also du findest sicherlich
tausende die drucke anschließen können oder die ein bisschen windows klicken
können aber gute programmierer oder sagen mal leute die sich mit modernen
cloud krempel auskennen oder auch linux experten und sonst wo das ist das
wächst alles nicht wie sand am mehr oder wie sagt man das gibt es nicht wie
sand am mehr und das wächst nicht wie wie heißt das spruch wie melonen an den
bäumen nee keg weight unkraut auf den bäumen
ach
bambus
das ist dann immer sieht es gibt 100.000 sprichwörter in der richtung
ok was suchen die all departments geht es schon ziemlich unübersichtlich
und die hat die suche aber doch die suche aber ganz schön viel ja def
ja full stack was jetzt
wenn man auch ob sucht gibt es nicht ok sie suchen ein full stack die
developer
das ist alles auf englisch hier heute ist belastend heute belastend
auch die sind mal richtig modern hier latest angela das wäre jetzt für mich
pains camp aber ich bin auch keine englische kraft ql richtig poggers typescript auch
richtig modern java 11 keine ahnung ich habe keine auf ich weiß auch nicht was
drop drop wizard ist
in den web framework für java oder so kafka auch voll angesagt das ist so
message message q geschichte das ist nein das ist kein buch also wenn schon ist
das denn denn autor philosoph aus dem frag mich nicht 19. jahrhundert oder so
ja gar nicht so schlecht aber das ist eine message q oder ich glaube ein
alter sie nennen sich nicht message q in den event event based event verteilte
event streaming plattform die mehrere billionen events pro tag verarbeiten
kann haben die haben die billion falsch übersetzt haben die billion falsch
übersetzt weil billion ist ja eigentlich nur milliarde
und zur verarbeitung von datenströmen ein verteiltes system das skalierbar und
fehler tolerant und somit für big data anwendung geeignet ist das ist doch
schon mal was hier dass das verwenden die big brain agilen enabler heutzutage
also sowas wie event hab in azure ehrlich gesagt kann ich nicht sagen wie
da der feature overlap ist
overview mir kommt das voll bekannt vor keeper xy bist du noch da haben wir das
nicht auf der arbeit was von denen mir kommt der name so bekannt voll linic
wie spricht man das überhaupt lien lien liene i x liene i x liene i x
für was benutzt man sowas in der realität also das simpelste beispiel für
was wir so eine message q verwendet ist zum beispiel als das erste was mir
einfällt sagt jetzt einfach zum beispiel von versenden von newslettern
oder so ja irgendein typ registriert sich in deinem job nicht nicht job
registriert sich in deinem shop klickt beim registrieren an ja ich will
newsletter oder neueste informationen haben so da geht dieses hat sich
registriert in der message q rein und beim nächsten durchlauf von der von dem
von dem job von dem service für newsletter zieht er sich das raus und
verschickt ein newsletter asynchron
so in der richtung aber jetzt vielleicht nicht das beste beispiel aber für so
was kann man das verwenden
klingt nach mq tt ja gut ist es ja im prinzip auch nur dass du kannst mit
kafka noch viel mehr machen das stimmt ich habe mich damit aber noch nicht im
detail so was wie aktiv mq genau so was wie rapid mq gibt es auch noch und und
so gibt es total viel zeug 0 mq wahnsinnig alles gibt du kannst mit kaffe
allerdings auch viel mehr machen ich muss aber ehrlich sagen ich habe mich
damit noch nicht großartig beschäftigt
kommt mal hier man muss englisch können german is a plus also sprich
hauptsächlich englisch aber die kommen wir in die kommen mir irgendwie bekannt
vor ich bilde mir fast ein wir haben irgendwas von denen auf der arbeit
nein wir haben nichts von ihnen wir haben wir haben was von atlas jen und da ist
wahrscheinlich was von denen mit drinne deswegen kommt mir das bekannt vor
wo sitzen die denn überhaupt im print friedrich ebert alli
das ist glaube ich mario 4 60 musik kann das sein
ich hätte gedacht dass die wüsten musik aber das habe ich dann habe ich
durcheinander gebracht ach nee das mario party
die jubilä jana liubiana slovenia in haider abad in indien ok die sind
wirklich international am start hier
aber wir haben schon ein paar ganz coole sachen gefunden die piraten die
piraten dann die java mages habt ihr noch irgendwelche coolen sachen die wir
uns angucken müssen ansonsten gucke ich jetzt mal hier bei den üblichen
verdächtigen jahr
haider abad hüter abad spricht man das aus ok
a ja jahre a ja jahr
moment die haben auch die die sehen auch schon alle so pirate mäßig aus ok das
wäre mir jetzt doch ein bisschen zu viel des guten also so wird sich so wird sich
die diese piratengeschichte finden aber ich müsste jetzt nicht wirklich im
teams meeting mit einer piratenmütze aufsetzen aufsitzen teilnehmen oder also
guck sie hier oben ist bestimmt zugeschaltet irgendwie aus asien und
denkt sich alle die deutschen haben rad ab
ja hier unten wird es richtig wissen guckt euch das mal an
augenklappe riesen bad mütz und headset auf jawoll
jetzt gerade auf dem gang oder so ja gut was auch immer also
jahre die leben das thema
das muss man ihnen tatsächlich zugute halten die all hooks und deck meeting im
prinzip all hooks an deck heißt nichts anderes wie dass es in den status
meeting wo alle dran teilnehmen na dann
du wirst bei uns nicht glücklich wenn du vollständige und durchgängige
prozesse wie in den konzerten großen konzernen erwartest es ist ein
unterschied also es gibt ja es gibt für mich einen guten guten mittelweg
zwischen es ist alles bis ins kleinste detail ausformuliert und alle flippen
aus wenn du dich nicht dran hältst und wir sind komplett planlos was wir machen
also ein guter mittelweg ist da finde ich das beste ja so prinzipielle abläufe
für sachen die häufig vorkommen und wo man auch quasi übergreifen gucken muss
was passiert vollkommen ok aber jeden furz der gelassen wird in den prozess zu
gießen finde ich dann zu übertrieben
es gibt freibier wirklich tatsächlich obstschalen freibier bälle bäder nein
bälle bäder brauche ich nicht wenn ich mich in so ein bällebad
reinschmeiß dann sind wahrscheinlich die bälle weg zu entwicklungsumgebung bei
uns gibt es viel mac os arch linux haben die arch linux ja immer arch by the
way und ubuntu ist auch dabei
windows haben wir noch nicht und wollen auch ungernes supporten die sind mir
sofort support sympathisch leute die magisch die können mir gestohlen bleiben
mit diesem ganzen pirate kram aber das macht die mir wirklich sympathisch
winners haben wir noch nicht und wollen und wollen auch ungernes support der
satz ist zwar fail aber das finde ich gut bewerbung ist raus instant bewerbung
bewerbung direkt direkt unterwegs hardware kannst du dir nach wünschen
aussuchen die meisten von uns entwickeln mit pp storm wim und wissel wim poggers
jawoll die sind richtig agil hier eindrücke von den büros findest du hier
ehrlich ich finde die machen gar keine so schlecht so schlechten eindruck
irgendwie finde ich das doch ich finde ohne scheiß so so painz champions am
anfang fange ich finde es doch jetzt echt ganz sympathisch was sie so ok die
stühle sehen naja ok wie zum teufel soll man denn da arbeiten
es ist ein raum mit einem tisch
das ist ein raum mit einem tisch oder wie
ja das ist mehr oder weniger ein raum mit einem tisch das ist eine wohnung das
ist eine wohnung mit zwei drei räumen und da haben die tische und stühle aber
hier kannst du nicht arbeiten
oder die kinder nur hin und die gehen da nur hin um freibier zu trinken und dann
gehen sie wieder heim
virtuelles büro jetzt machen waren sie auch schon games
irgendwie finde ich die aber doch ganz sympathisch ich weiß ich ihr wisst ich
bin nicht so der wahnsinns fern von so super familiären startup dingern ja
also für mich ist das arbeiten und keine familie aber irgendwie finde ich die
doch ganz sympathisch warum ist das alles auf englisch moment das ist putt
das ist das ist nicht für bewerber das ist für potenzielle kunden
how to get started you can create a label manually upload an address list
hier kleine prinzessin ich glaube nicht dass sie zu viel geld haben ich glaube
nicht dass sie zu viel geld haben so start-up dingern neigen zumindest habe
ich den eindruck ich kann das natürlich jetzt nicht belegen ob sie der mein
eindruck der sich da immer aufwächst die geben geld für so was aus was sie
eigentlich nicht haben oder es brummt bei den richtig ok jetzt gucken wir mal was
haben die für bewertung ok vier bewertungen das ist natürlich nichts
sagens paid actors würde ich sagen oder steht da was von familie
ja gut bei vier bewertungen kannst du da wirklich nichts drauf geben jetzt aber
ich irgendwie sind die mir doch ganz sympathisch ich kann es jetzt nicht
genau sagen warum aber ich finde es jetzt nach dem nach dem anfangen mit dem
pirate team wo ich gedacht habe das ist ja pence jam finde ich die eigentlich doch
ganz ok wahrscheinlich weil sie gesagt haben sie mögen kein wind aus
peter agile können sterben aber was ist denn cap terra pirate ship pricing ich
weiß nicht was es ist paket und frachttransport make your shipping
jeep 1 bis 10 beschäftigte die hatten aber viel mehr hier auf auf ihrer seite
ja ja ich glaube ich jetzt nicht ein naja naja so hat noch jemand irgendwas cool
ist was ich unbedingt zeigen muss im nächsten video ja das stimmt das bei
denen wird mich das nicht wundern wenn die die surfer wirklich im keller stehen
hätten dort links über sehen wenn du rockstar developer werden möchtest
ach so ja ne das kann ich das das habe ich schon mal gesehen
so dann gucken wir mal was haben sie hier schöne sachen für uns
ach das waren die mit nettei wo ich keine ahnung hatte was es war so deck so
gut scheine es ist denn so deck so ich so doku
gibt es zufällig bei twitch jobs gucken wir doch mal schauen wir mal
du siehst in purple open jobs was ist der unterschied zwischen open jobs und
internships ist das hier quasi kann es jederzeit
rausgeschmissen werden und das nicht oder
ach praktikum das ist ein praktikum
suchen die auch was in deutschland
senior software developer engineer in berlin suchen die was hier jawoll
berlin
senior software engineer und i gdb was was für ein ding was ist das
ist die twitch twitch game database oder habe ich noch nie gesehen
das ist so was wie im db für games aber gibt es da nicht schon metacritic man
kann auch keine ok keine ahnung was das ist
produce clean high quality code tests and documentation sie ist noch nicht
mal bei twitch hat sich das schon rumgesprochen gerade twitch müsste es
doch eigentlich wissen guter code dokumentiert sich selbst
was wollen die alle immer mit dokumentation schreiben ich verstehe es
überhaupt nicht alle wollen sie immer dass man dokumentation schreibt viel
wichtiger ist doch dass man ordentliches zeug programmiert was man sofort
verstehen easy einfach so programmieren dass man es direkt versteht und man
braucht nie wieder dokumentieren easy
verstehe ich net
könnte ich dann sagen ich dann könnte ich mich bei twitch bewerben und dann
sage ich einfach alles was mich an twitch stört und dann gehe ich wieder
das wäre auch hier big brain move readiness to try new things ok ok 6 plus
years alles klar drei plus years web application back and things model view
controller database management at scale concurrency data modeling distributed
system fundamentals die wollen es müssen hier
aws na gut wenn twitch nicht aws benutzt wer sonst steht da wirklich was von
ruby drin tatsächlich ja gut twitch war noch mal moment bring ich das jetzt
durcheinander bring ich das jetzt durch ne twitter twitter war mal ruby on rails
und twitter ist jetzt java oder skala also irgendwas auf jvm basis sind ich
glaube ich jetzt die haben ja umgestellt schon vor zehn jahren oder
so aber am anfang war twitter war auch ruby und rails und ich glaube github ist
immer noch ruby und rails kann das sein jitthap
gibt es eigentlich den unterschied gibt es eigentlich den unterschied zwischen
mvf ja ja gibt es ok moment jetzt jetzt muss ich mal kurz in mich gehen also
hier ist der sinn du hast dein du hast deine deine sau deine daten models du
hast einen controller zum ändern dieser sachen und du hast einen view zum
anzeigen so und bei model view view model geht's
glaube ich darum du hast eine du hast deine datenobjekte du hast einen view
also den gui in dem fall zum beispiel ja in den frontend so und dann hast du
noch einen view model was darf wo du quasi also du beides dein view nicht
direkt an das model du beides deinen view an das view model also sprich das view
model bereitet ein model so weit auf dass es sich gut von dem view verarbeiten
lässt so was auch immer ich glaube jetzt weiß man es nachher immer noch nicht
genau aber also das ist so wie ich das jetzt aus dem kopf raus sagen würde ja
messer für controller mvvm skaliert besser ja wie gesagt diagonal twitter
implementation ruby genau genau genau
genau java haben sie jetzt was ist denn gesagt skala
ja ja gut es ist immer noch java
wieder so theoretische konzepte die nur den korn auf den einfach alles in die
code behind datei schreiben und mit windows forms machen easy das ist der
way to go windows forms code behind so geht das oder
oder oder gleich einfach alles in elektron dann braucht man sich überhaupt
nichts mehr gedanken machen macht man einfach alles in css oder html
jedes mit zu scary die musik
ja aber gut das wundert mich nicht dass twitch leute haben will die amazon sachen
können man das zeug wird ja auch also man kann ja viel über twitch sagen aber
seit der amazon übernahme ist gerade was verfügbarkeit angeht und gelerke und so
ist schon besser geworden twitch war da vor dafür kann ich keine mehr
davor doch schon teilweise recht recht oft procken kommt immer noch vor aber
nicht mehr so oft wieder vor
waren wir schon bei discord jobs gucken nee aber das hat auch keinen sinn da zu
gucken da ist nichts lustiges dabei dass sie ganz normalen job anzeigen
sollte das nicht eigentlich soll das nicht eigentlich normal sein
alles müssen sie noch mal explizit hervorheben
sehen sie den twitch für diese position eingestellt hat pass auf da kommt es
log in gleich bäm war klar link in immer immer der gleiche schritt hast du keine
existenzängste wegen den lokal lokalisierten abos ich habe mir das bis
heute nicht genauer angeguckt aber nee existenzängste habe ich selten ok da
ist nichts spannendes dabei eine offene du kultur
digga wenn ich viel besser als du kultur da bist du kein programmer da bist du
ein bro krammer digga ins chat max ich sehe in der chat mag meine wetter heute
wieder richtig eindeutig eindeutig zu erkennen ja
walla fix ma back genau so muss das sein du kultur ist auch digga kultur ist ganz
angesagt
digga bro fühle ich fühle ich digga selber dauernd
fühle ich und eine spannende aufgabe ok alles klar weißt du was walla wirklich
ich glaube das heißt so viel wie ich schwör oder heißt es nicht ich glaube
man schreibt übrigens auch mit v heißt es nicht so viel wie ich schwör ich
schwör auf mit das kann das kann das kann das kann nicht heißen ich schwöre
auf gott ich meine das kann doch nicht sein dass es ein wort gibt und das
heißt ich schwör auf warum brauchen wir vier wörter dafür und da heißt es
einfach nur walla jetzt ergibt das sinn ok anscheinend macht man das dort so oft
in arabischen kulturkreisen dass man da auf gott schwört dass es da schon ein
eigenes wort für gibt bei uns bei uns sagen leute ich schwör auf meine mutter
oder was sagt man sagt man da ich heute ich war früher solche was ich war früher
bei den fahrtfindern da musste man auch sachen schwören
da musste man sachen schwören um ein neues halsbändchen zu kriegen
aber zu lieber auf vertrauensarbeitszeit oder auf stunden stunden stunden ich
mache ich mache lieber zeitabrechnung da kann auch keiner ankommen mit wie hier
am wochenende ist noch und sonst wie als bändchen ja kenne ich ja nein nein
bei den fahrtfinder nicht das hatte mit gott nichts zu tun
fahrtfinder hals tuch ja genau so die haben wir dann gekriegt und dann musste
man ab einem gewissen alter durfte man dann durfte man an dinger dinger schwören
und und dann hat man neues halsband gekriegt ja so war das ich weiß gar
nicht ob sie überhaupt noch heute noch zulauf an an leuten bei bei den bei den
fahrtfindern gibt ja da war ich früher und ich war ich weiß auch noch so
ungefähr was ich geschwört habe allerdings nur eine sache ich habe
geschwört ich habe ich habe versprochen hat man sie aber hat er
nicht geht nicht nicht geschwört hat man jetzt ich schwöre ich weiß es gar
nicht mehr zumindest da habe ich geschworen habe ich
geschworen dass ich oma ist richtig hängen geblieben mir ist sonst nichts
eingefallen das weiß ich dass ich oma über die straße helfe und dass wenn ich
sehe dass einer ich glaube ich weiß gar nicht ob ich glaube dass wenn ich
irgendwie sehe dass einer irgendwie die natur verschmutzt dass ich dann sage
lasst das sein oder so ja mal davon abgesehen hey ich würde heute mal ich
würde heute wirklich da oma über die straße helfen wenn die probleme hätte
heute ist es aber eher umgedreht stellt euch mal vor heute steht eine oma an der
straße und du kommst wie sieht es wie sieht es aus kann ich ihnen behilflich
sein nein gehen sie weg kommen sie mir nicht zu nahe die lässt sich heute gar
nicht helfen
omas helfen max über die straße ja ja mittlerweile mittlerweile ist es schon
so weit ja das habe ich damals damals geschworen bei den fahrtfindern wie das
übrigens mit allen schwüren so ist im prinzip passiert nichts wenn du dich
nicht dran hält also deswegen wird ja auch gerade in der politik so viel zeug
versprochen wenn der tag lang ist und im nächstes am nächsten tag weiß es
keiner mehr
genau das sagt die oma dann die oma sagt an wenn ich frag kann ich darf ich
ihnen über die straße helfen oder kann sie behilflich sein sagt die oma dann
von mir zu mir
ok was haben wir sonst noch schönes ja
oder boomer boomer zeit gleich ist boomer zeit eine halbe stunde
leute habt ihr nicht noch irgendwelche lustigen stellen anzeigen ich brauche
fürs nächste video noch ein paar ansonsten ist nicht schlimm die die ich
jetzt habe reichen auch dann suche ich mir noch eins zwei normale und was ich
im nächsten video unbedingt machen muss ich muss mal am anfang kurz einblenden
was die geantwortet haben weil es haben zwei leute also zwei unternehmen schon
reagiert auf diese auf mich also ich habe reagiert auf ihre stellen anzeigen sie
haben auf mich reaktet und haben gesagt ich habe das ja alles komplett falsch
verstanden
sport rocker im letzten video und im ersten video
wartet mal so leute jungs im ersten video hat auch irgendeine firma drauf
reagiert ich glaube da immer her und scrum da wurden wundert müssen ja die
gewesen sein die hier haben reagiert wie heißen die stack so was haben wir denn
hier du wünschst dir auf mucken statt klappe
halten das kram mehr konfin pro konfin die haben auch reagiert die haben auch
reagiert irgendwo hier und auf twitter was bei wagner jobs soll ich gucken ist
wagner sind das sie mit der mit der mit der pizza
und all da ist das lang sind das sie mit der pizza
ach das ist eine marketing agentur das ist ja langweilig arbeiten bei wagner
wagner geht das sieht jetzt alles relativ normal
aus offene stellen php entwickler das ist ja genau das genau meins
auch die wollen die die wollen schon mal hier miem punkte sammeln nur dass es
irgendwie nur verhalten lustig ist php entwickler
das hier sieht doch alles noch ganz normal aus ganz schön trist oder ist es
ein ein großes büro und das war es ok ja das ist ein großes büro und das war
es
das ist modern aber man kann nicht gescheit arbeiten und hat keine ruhe das
ist dann zwar modern aber nervig und warum haben die teilweise anzüge an ich
möchte kein anzug worte warum ist an der axt
der kündigst bekommt die axt so viele wagner
ja es sieht doch ganz normal aus application engineer meine güte haben die da haben die
da ihre gesamte lebenslauf gründer vom kindergarten bis zum start up reingeschrieben
oder ok als application engineer blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla blablabla
druck und verpackungsunternehmer verpackungs design verpackungs die haben da wirklich den
ganzen tagesablauf reingeschrieben jetzt ernsthaft wie sieht ein tag als application
engineer aus das ist 8 uhr 30 und sie machen sich auf den weg zu ihrem kunden ok ich bin
raus leute ich bin weg da musst du kunden fahren heute ist es ein etiketten hersteller
schön für ihn ich fahre trotzdem nicht hin der kunde hat gerade esko software gekauft
artios katt oder c ad spricht c ad
was ist das
das sieht aus wie windows 95 gui
ist es wahrscheinlich auch
ok und möchten sie so schnell wie möglich in betrieb nehmen die software ist anscheinend
richtig big brain die kann man nicht einfach installieren da braucht man den experten
vom hersteller was hässliche ribbons hatten die da echt ribbons drauf keine ribbons hier
gibt es keine ribbons keine ribbons hier nirgends wo ribbons leute jebaited mich nicht alles keine
ribbons sieht aber richtig antik aus der kram so nach einem stellenkraft blabla blabla blabla
richtig geile experten hier
zukünftigen experten das wort mögen sie das
aber als entwickler entwickler da sachen installieren ist auch schon komisch
oder bist du als application engineer gar kein entwickler
den kunden zu helfen ist das was ihnen an ihrer rolle am meisten spaß macht ja also da da finde
ich mich ja voll wieder drin also ich gehe auch jeden tag auf die arbeit und denke mir
bin ich froh dass ich wieder den kunden helfen darf ich helfe kunden einfach so gerne das ist
was mir an meiner rolle am meisten spaß macht gibt es jemand der sowas macht ich weiß nicht
also vielleicht sie sind das gesicht und die stimme des kunden innerhalb von esko
ich glaube da geht es nicht ums programmieren das heißt nur so
das ist warum ist das in application engineer das ist ernen das ist ernen vor ort sales support
stellz mann in application bla bla bla subject matters was für ein ding subject matters experts
wer kann sich echt für alles irgendwelche beknackten abkürzungen und begriffe ausdenken das
wird wahrscheinlich internet dann auch noch abgekürzt als sme oder sowas das da auch gar
nicht mehr weiß um was es geht ok also was muss man denn können guter kommunikator flexibilität
im reisen null nein mvt für andere menschen nein gut dazu nein
deutsch fließen oder auf muttersprachler niveau jetzt wollen sie es aber echt wissen
gelegentlich wird von ihnen erwartet dass die kollegen bei der bearbeitung von software
support fällen unterstützen also quasi halb first level noch dabei
entweder zwei plus jahre erfahrung im bereich structural design für verpackung oder esko soft
ja mal ganz im ernst gibt es wirklich jemand der das hat structural design für verpackung so
viele dürfte es da nicht geben und mit esko software wahrscheinlich auch nicht ok es geht
hier überhaupt nicht um den entwickler aber warum heißt er den application engineer wenn
es mit entwickler überhaupt gar nichts zu tun hat was das ist was für ein ding ok es
hat überhaupt nichts damit zu tun dass das klingt wie den entwickler ist es aber nicht
ja gut dann ich
bett veteranen status das ist so ein typisches ding was die amis immer reinschreiben dass
ja das ist so ein typisches ding was die amis immer reinschreiben
veteranen status ist glaube ich jetzt in deutschland nicht so das ding wo wo irgendwie besonders dann
drauf geguckt wird aber bei den amis ist das so da steht das auch immer drin veteranen status
guck mal es gibt wirklich welche die fachinformatiker systemintegration suchen oder ist das eine
ausbildung move your future superheld das fängt schon an
das geht schon gut los es das ist interessant weil normalerweise sucht niemand einen fachinformatiker
systemintegration sondern meistens nur leute die das unter anderem gelernt haben aber die
bezeichnung heißt dann anders für was wahrscheinlich typischer turnschuhe admin job installation
konfiguration betrieb war schon komplexer ja das ist wieder so eine so eine mach alles
so eine turnschuhe admin admin geschichte stellen umsetzt dokumentieren von richtigen
sicherheits vorschriften zukunftsberechtigung alles klar fehleranalyse behebung it infrastruktur
ok so ein typischer admin für alles suchen die im endeffekt unterstützung der anwender
second level support ok was auch immer die sich darunter vorstellen einweisung und schulung
der anwender ja das ist im prinzip eher so was wie du stellst den drucker hin und zeigst
ihn wie man damit druck vermute ich mal vermute ich mal ich finde manche hätten manche würden
gut daran tun es nicht so hoch hochdrabend immer zu schreiben weil dann wirkt das so
als suchen die wirklich so die so die den experte in allen bereichen ich gehe davon
aus die meinen damit du schließt den drucker an und zeigst dem typ halt auch noch wie man
wie man damit was druckt beratung bei der auswahl und beschaffung von it infrastruktur pflege
eine homogen umgebung bestehen aus sovors firewalls und hp aruba ruby switching infrastrukturen
ok das ist allein schon wieder so ein job für sich wenn man das gut machen will aber
wahrscheinlich musste da nicht mehr machen als ab und zu mal ein paar firewall regel
einschreibt reinschreiben bist du orange muss ich orange sein dachte hautfarbe spielt
keine rolle vollende grundlagen solltest du auf jeden fall mitbringen du hast ein abgeschlossen
ja du verfügst über gute kenntnisse netzwerk technologien tcp ip router switch ja danach
bist du netzwerk profi keine frage und in windows server und clients ok pains jam da
hätte ich keinen plassen schimmer von du bringst fundierte erfahrung im alti betrieb mit
sozial bla bla bla aber am allerwichtigsten du passt zu uns du bist teamfisch offen geht
positiv einer herausforderung heran genau das suchen wir wollen wir mal gucken ob sport rocker
ob die das aktualisiert haben ich glaube wir haben es hier immer noch drinnen nein es ist
weg sport rocker nicht dass sie pleite sind hoffe ja nicht aber ich ja noch vielleicht mit dran
schuld ok ne die gibt es immer noch die gibt es immer noch bleite wegen macht ja bleite weil
die stellenanzeige geflammt habe ok jobs ansehen auf haben die haben das haben das wirklich die
haben das wirklich rausgeschmissen was ich da gut es könnte aber auch sein dass die einen gefunden
haben moment bild hat auch eine jobs seite so bnd und lkb ka stellen ja wenn du welche welche
hast ich glaube da haben wir ganz am anfang schon mal geguckt die waren jetzt nicht so nicht so
spannend die waren meistens sehr oldschool geschrieben und die bezahlung sah meistens auch
jetzt nicht so nicht so toll aus wobei ich die logik da noch nicht genau verstanden habe ab
wie vielen jahren man welche stufe bekommt und wie das da genau läuft was interamt hat welche was
ist denn interamt interamt was interamt das stellenbörder ist öffentlich das ist den ihre
jobbörse quasi also quasi dort wo die ganzen jobs drin sind warum brauchen die da schon wieder
was eigenes für kirchen euer da wollte da will ich hin sag ja evangelische brückenschlag gemeinde
köln flittert stramm stamm ja genau und jetzt noch in der it ich will für ich will kirche
und it arbeiten und wie kann man da überhaupt suchen jetzt wie suche ich denn da überhaupt
nach it jetzt gar nicht sucht sucht text und dann it ein angebot der beauftragte für den
datenschutz der ekd datenschutz für die evangelische kirche in deutschland muss man
da muss man da mitglied mit muss man da evangelisch sein um das machen zu können also offiziell
dürfen sie es nicht offiziell dürfen sie es nicht aber wahrscheinlich werden sie wert
darauf legen und halt sagen es passt nicht wenn es nicht hast genau vorm vorstellungsgespräch
erst mal eine runde beten wir bitten um einen hinweis in ihrer in ihren bewerbungsunterlagen
dass sie die evangelischen kirchen beziehungsweise einer kirche der arbeitsgemeinschaft christlicher
kirchen es ist erforderlich darf man das ist das ist das darf man das das ist bestimmt
die krauzone ich verstehe es also ich verstehe das schon aus denen ihrer sicht aber ich
weiß nicht ob man das darf na gut ist mir ehrlich gesagt doch vollkommen egal das will
ich eh nicht machen tja man kann leider nicht ach hier technischer dienst ich weiß nicht
diesem ganzen diesem ganzen amtzeug haftet einfach so unglaublich so eine so eine staub
bürokratie schicht an das liest sich auch immer in diesen stellen anzeigen so also das
wirkt alles immer so unglaublich behäbig und old school und und wie aus dem letzten
Jahrtausend einfach nur startplanung netzwerkadministratorinnen netzwerkadministratorin die
sind alles andere als agil ein gruppierung erfolgt in die endgeldgruppe 11 tvl ok das
ist wahrscheinlich wieder gar nichts gucken wir mal 11 ok wenn du stufe 6 bist ist in
ordnung also stufe 6 kann man kann man kann man machen ja wann ist man dann stufe 6 wie
viel verdienst du ungefähr 70.000 im jahr mal 0,8 weil ich nur vier tage arbeite dann
hast du es ungefähr recht gut was ich verdiene so wie wird man so jetzt mal guckt euch die
seite an die sieht schon aus wie von 1995
ich meine das geht schon in ordnung je nachdem
naja ich habe es aufgegeben dadurch durch zu blicken wie das wie das da bezahlt wird
öffentliche sachen das check ich nicht sie sind für die administration von netzwerkkomponenten
zustände ja ok das hätte ich mir gedacht als netzwerkadministrator 70 kam mit 12 oder
13 gehälter mit 14 ich habe ich habe wirklich alles schon mit reingerechnet deswegen sage
ich aber so über den daumen gepeilt 70k und ja ich weiß bevor die ersten wieder ankommen
würde ich habe mit jobwechsel kriegst du mehr ist mir wurscht
in bayern würdest du das nicht bekommen ok so ja und weil die frage kommt was ich mache
guckt euch mal an ich habe da ein komplettes video drüber gemacht da guck mal da könnt
ihr euch angucken 14 minuten warum auch immer border also das video ist schon älter weil
borderlands 3 im hintergrund muss von 2090 können euch anhören das stimmt zum größten
teil auch noch was ich da in dem video erzähle was ich mache
schon spät ja noch in acht minuten ist es ist ist es bettzeit also was wollen die diese
schriftart hier macht triggert mich schon warum muss alles was ämter machen so krass
nach amt und schimmel aussehen vielleicht stehen darauf dass es aussieht wie eine schreibmaschine
oder so wobei ich den font an sich in so einem editor ganz ganz ganz ok fendt finden würde
aber die pflegen ausstellung sie betreuen kunde ok was wollen sie ihr profil die erfüllung
bei einer hochschule erworbenes bachelor in der informat
warum soll ich ein bachelor haben als netzwerk admin was in welcher welt leben die eigentlich
ok alternativ bringen sie den staatlichen abschluss als operative profett das ja das
ist die ik weiterbildung das ist die ik weiterbildung die kein die irgendwie kaum einer macht kennt
ihr irgendjemand der operative professionell gemacht hat bei der ik ich kenne nicht einen
ach echt da sei du machst das interessant ich kenne wirklich niemand der das macht ok oder
sie weisen eine langjährige einschläge beruf der erfahrung in der it nach ok da wenigstens
ist hier so ist pence gem teilweise sie bringen kenden ist über netzwerk protokolle beispielsweise
tcp ip snmp osbf was ist denn ist das spending tree soll das spending tree sein spending tree
ja ok aber dass die das hinten dran schreiben das geht zumindest schon in die netzwerk richtung
mein spending tree ist eigentlich eine sache in dem um dass du dich in der regel nicht
kümmern musst mal big brain frage für was braucht man spending tree was vermeidet man
mit spending tree also wofür ist das eigentlich erfunden worden kreisel kreisende rahmen loops
ja richtig der chat der chat ist hat sich eindeutig gelohnt dass so viele leute subscribt
haben der iq des chats ist einfach richtig weit richtig weit oben es spending tree ist
dafür erfunden worden dass man schleifen in seinem netzwerk equipment vermeidet also
sprich also auf switch auf layer 2 ebene also sprich wenn du den switch hast und den verbindest
du mit mehr als einem port miteinander du nimmst du nimmst zwei switch und steckst dort quasi
vier ports zusammen dann hast du ja das problem dass du nicht weißt wo du eigentlich hin musst
weil das könnte ja dann wie auch immer und dann schaltet spending tree einfach alles aus so dass
es nur noch einen sinnvollen gültigen weg gibt ohne schleifen moment wo start stand stand
das jetzt wo war ich jetzt eigentlich gerade ja so snp ist meistens ganz nützlich für monitoring
von netzwerk equipment spf ist ein routing protokoll spf benutzt du da wo du viele netze
hast und die automatisch verteilen muss dass die router wissen wo was ist also meistens ist es so
in der regel ausnahmen beschädigen die regel meistens benutzt man intern spf und zwischen den
netzen ist es dann bgp oder bg bg bgp da muss man sich aber dann meistens keine gedanken
drüber machen weil das dein provider handelt intern machst du meistens spf früher hat man
noch dings gemacht wie ist das ripp hieß das früher ne press f protokoll glaub ripp war
so das erste routing routing protokoll in der richtung und dann gab es noch die sysco variante
da habe ich aber vergessen wie die heißt i grip oder so zumindest heutzutage verwenden
eigentlich alle spf ripp ist auch easy das stellst du deinem router einfach ein welche netze er kennt
und fertig und drück machst ein hickchen an und es funktioniert ich hätte es wünschen
veraktiv das hp verwenden sowohl ok wlan automatisierungslosen ansible puppet chef ok
nice wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss rein syntaktisch und vom vom handling her wir machen
so viel puppet auf der arbeit aber ich habe ja privat jetzt ein bisschen ansible gemacht und auch
beispielsweise die ganze den preis jam damit automatisiert und ein paar zinger gemacht vom
handling her muss ich sagen gefällt mir ansible einfach umlängen besser als puppet und chef hat
nichts mit pepo fett zu tun das ist eine ruby basierte automatisierungslösung glaube verwendet
kaum noch einer puppet und ansible ist sollsteck ist glaubt auch noch recht beliebt und fürs
provisioning terraform script sprachen shell python bash naja gut das kommt ja mehr oder
weniger aufs gleiche raus ja ich weiß das ist noch ein bisschen älter aber in der regel ist
damit heutzutage eigentlich best gemeint sie verfügen über gute deutschkenntnis ok
das ist schon vorbei da ist schon vorbei und grundkenntnis der englischen sprache
die bereitschaft zu vor Ort einsetzen in den Wochenendeinsätzen ist voraus
warum schreiben die sowas nicht dahin ganz im ernst warum schreiben die sowas nicht direkt
oben hin den liest den ganzen scheiß durch also mal genommen man interessiert sich dafür
liest den ganzen scheiß durch und dann siehst du und tschüss man kann mit dem video rechnen
der vielleicht vielleicht übermorgen vielleicht auch am freitag
jeder was von homeoffice ach tatsächlich zum beispiel homeoffice flexible arbeit sein ja zum
beispiel homeoffice da mal gucken da wird mir interessieren wird mich mal interessieren wie
das mit homeoffice machen wollen wenn vor orteinsätze wochenendeinsätze in rufbereitschaft
du machst quasi rufbereitschaft während du homeoffice machst oder wie stellen die sich das vor
ja offenes arbeitsklima ok es gibt auch im prinzip am ähnliches keine vorteile nichts was hier
steht irgendwie geile vorteile wir leben vielfalt wir freuen uns besonders über bewerbung von
frauen ja dann passen wir doch perfekt zusammen da kann man sich doch einfach für die bewerbung
als frau identifizieren easy job abgreifen und danach wieder als mann das müssen wir eigentlich
machen das ist eigentlich der six hat muß schlechthin im jahr 2021 wenn es muss das
muss man echt mal ausprobieren ob das klappt das muss man echt mal auswählen ob das klappt
wenn die irgendwo schreiben frauen werden bevorzugt was auch immer einfach nur so just for fun
so sehr bräuchte natürlich noch den passenden namen und ihr wisst ihr dürft mich da nicht
mehr max nennen weil das ist dead naming und das ist ganz fies und dann ist vorbei dann
ist instant anzeige raus da muss ich mir erst mal neuen namen aus ausdenken was ist denn
ein ein ein wohl klingender frauen name für mich maxime nein nein maxi mann was ganz
anderes manuela beate beate das klingt so der klassiker der klassiker was ist denn so
eine richtig was ist so richtig oldschool gertrude oder sowas gut ruhen gertrude gertrude
finde ich gut gertrude finde ich gut brunn hilde ist auch nicht schlecht ja aber ich
glaube gertrude finde ich gut ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube gertrude wird's gertrude
agile muss oma gertrude nicht ins bett doch von zwei minuten über der zeit leute fack
jetzt vorbei oder spaß ist zu ende keck weight jetzt ist jetzt zu spät jetzt vorbei ausgelacht
hier ob es irgendjemand gibt den ich hausen kann aber kommen wir hausen wieder ist ist
der hot ist mein hot tube stream noch an wie der hot tube stream ist auf na gut da kann
ich jetzt kein hausen da kann ich jetzt kein hausen keiner und was ist das
oder oder
ne youtube hatte ich rate limited dreck säge kitboga kitboga ist wirklich nice also wenn
ich einem den erfolg auf twitch wirklich komplett gönne auch vom konter der ist das eher also
der macht das unglaublich gut leute ich gehe jetzt auf ich gebe hin wir sehen uns die tage
hier bis denn c u